der Staatsbürger unseres Landes werden
will in der Regel seine alte
Staatsbürgerschaft abgeben sollte und
nur in begründeten Fällen und das ist
die geltende Rechtslage sollen davon
Ausnahmen geben soll es davon Ausnahmen
geben das gilt etwa für Staatsangehörige
aus EU-Ländern weil wir mit Ihnen einen
gemeinsame Werte und Rechtsordnung
teilen und es gibt auch andere
europäische Länder die dieses
regelausnahmeverhältnis kennen die
generelle doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
sie führt auch zu Loyalitätskonflikten
ich will Ihnen nur zwei Beispiele nennen
finden Sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel es wirklich gut
wenn zum Beispiel deutsche
Kriegsdienst für ein anderes Land
leisten ist es nicht besser wenn
Staatsbürger aus autokratisch regierten
Staaten ihre Staatsbürgerschaft aufgeben
und sich damit auch ganz klar für unser
demokratisches System entscheiden müssen
ich glaube nicht dass die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft die zentrale Lösung
unseres Arbeitskräftemangels darstellt
es braucht dafür andere Lösungen es
braucht gute Strukturen in unserem Land
es braucht finanzielle Anreize und ein
generelles zulassen der doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft wird den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt in
unserem Land nicht stärken sondern
Schwächen
und genau das gilt auch für den zweiten
zentralen Punkt ihrer
staatsbürgerschaftsreform sie wollen die
Fristen wie lange jemand in Deutschland
vor der Einbürgerung gelebt haben muss
nahezu halbieren Ausländer sollen
künftig statt nach acht Jahren schon
nach fünf Jahren eingebürgert werden und
bei besonderen Integrationsleistungen
schon nach Stadt nach sechs Jahren schon
nach drei Jahren so kurze Fristen wie
der sprechen unserem unserer Sicht aus
unserer Sicht im Prinzip dass die
Einbürgerung das erfolgreiche Ende eines
Integrationsprozesses sein sollte und
nicht an dessen Anfang stehen darf und
sie verletzen das Prinzip von fördern
und fördern
Integration liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen braucht Zeit und sie sollte
nachhaltig sein sie sollte am Ende mit
der Einbürgerung belohnt werden und
selbst Schweden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampelkoalition dass sie
uns jahrelang als modernes und
fortschrittliches Land in der
einwanderungs- und Einbürgerungspolitik
als Vorbild verkauft haben genau dieses
Land ist sowohl restriktiver geworden
bei seiner Einwanderungspolitik und als
Antwort auf erhebliche gesellschaftliche
Spannungen prüft dort nun eine
Regierungskommission die
einbürgerungsfrist von bislang fünf auf
mindestens acht Jahre zu verlängern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
auch an dieser Stelle sollte man genau
nach Schweden schauen wenn man hier in
Deutschland weitere Vorschläge
unterbreitet
wir sollten in diesen Zeiten vorsichtig
sein wir sollten uns erlernt und die
Menschen nicht überfordern ihr
Gesetzentwurf wenn er denn vorliegt den
werden wir genau prüfen wir werden ihn
genau analysieren denn es gibt noch viel
mehr Punkte zu klären als nur die beiden
von mir angesprochenen
allein schon die Halbierung der
Aufenthaltszeiten ist kein Punkt den wir
so mitgehen können aber wir werden Ihren
Antrag und ihren Gesetzentwurf wenn sie
sich denn einig werden ganz genau prüfen
und dann auch dazu noch mal Stellung
beziehen vielen Dank
für die Bundesregierung hat das Wort die
Staatsministerin Bremen alibali Radovan
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gut dass es
dieser aktuelle Stunde gibt dann können
wir noch einmal aufräumen Liebe Union
mit ihren Märchen und Mythen die richtig
gefährlich für unseren Zusammenhalt sind
gerade erst recht in diesen Zeiten
ihre Worte in der Union
mit dem Pass um sich werfen Black Friday
Sonderangebot sozialtourismus was ist
das für eine Sprache unsere Agenda
Respekt für Lebensleistung Zugehörigkeit
zu unserem Land und endlich besser
schneller und mehr einbürgern darum geht
es liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Kanzler und ich haben am Montag
einige der Menschen getroffen um die es
geht die sich eingebürgert haben die das
jetzt Vorhaben oder andere dabei
unterstützen wir trafen Frauen und
Männer die unser Land Vorrang bringen
und deren Eltern und Großeltern das auch
schon getan haben auch dank ihnen sind
wir ein starkes Land in der Mitte
Europas denken sie eigentlich auch an
diese Menschen wenn sie mit diesen
Worten um sich schmeißen das ist ein
Schlag in die Gesichter von 22 Millionen
Menschen mit familiärer
Einwanderungsgeschichte die hier ihre
Heimat haben mehr als die Hälfte davon
mit doppelten Pass und so viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieses diesen
Hohen Hauses die ebenfalls eingebürgert
sind auch in ihrer Fraktion Liebe Union
die interessanterweise bei dieser
Debatte nicht dabei sind
wie so viele
wie so viele mussten auch meine Eltern
lange und hart dafür kämpfen und ich
sage sehr bewusst an dieser Stelle
stoppen Sie die Respektlosigkeit kommen
sie in der Lebensrealität unseres Landes
an
denn seien wir doch ehrlich die deutsche
Integrationspolitik hatte immer
Verspätung beim einbürgern beim
teilhaben vieles hätten wir schon vor
Jahrzehnten gebrauchen können aber jetzt
packen wir das endlich an wir bringen
unser Einwanderungsland auf die Höhe der
Zeit mit einer Koalition des Aufbruchs
und des Fortschritts mit einer Mehrheit
in diesem Hause mit einer
Bundesregierung die es ernst meint
drei Punkte worum es uns bei der Reform
geht erstens mehr Respekt wir wollen
Lebens- und Integrationsleistungen
anerkennen mit kürzeren Fristen mit
weniger Hürden und dir Hingabe von
Mehrstaatlichkeit warum sollte nicht
jemand deutsche oder Deutscher sein der
hier fünf Jahre rechtmäßig lebt sein
Lebensunterhalt sichert die Sprache
spricht und sich zum Grundgesetz bekennt
hier wird von einigen so getan als sei
das im Vergleich viel zu kurz dabei ist
es in vielen Ländern längst Normalität
warum sollten wir Menschen so viel
länger hinhalten als in Kanada
Frankreich oder die USA das war und ist
nicht klug einbürgern dass es kein
Gnadenakt kein verramschen kein
pull-faktor liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
einbürgern
einbürgern das ist das gute Recht vom
Menschen die sich hier einbringen wir
wollen das modernste einbürgerungsrecht
der Welt dafür steht diese Reform liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zweitens mehr Demokratie wer viele Jahre
hier lebt der soll neben allen Pflichten
auch alle Rechte haben unsere Demokratie
lebt von der Möglichkeit mit zu
bestimmen zu wählen und gewählt zu
werden es ist nicht gut wenn
Einwohnerschaft und wahlfolg immer
weiter auseinanderfallen und das kann
uns nicht zufriedenstellen
es kann uns nicht zufriedenstellen dass
wir im letzten Jahr mit
132.000 Einbürgerung nur 2,5 Prozent
beim einbürgerungspotenzial ausschöpfen
darum verbessern wir jetzt dem Weg zur
Einbürgerung wollen wir stärker um die
Menschen werden darum werde ich auch
eine
einbürgerungskampagne auf den Weg
bringen
und drittens mehrfachkräfte für mehr
Wohlstand es geht um die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes
deutschland muss sich anstrengen im
Wettbewerb um die klügsten Köpfe es ist
ein Mythos das alle Schlange stehen und
darauf warten hierher zu kommen und in
Deli Dakar und Dallas wird unsere
debattenklima sehr aufmerksam verfolgt
veranschen kommt da gar nicht gut an
weder hier noch dort
nein wir müssen hart dafür arbeiten
das Fachkräfte zu uns einwandern und
bleiben wir brauchen Sie dafür haben wir
gestern im Kabinett die Eckpunkte für
ein modernes Einwanderungsrecht
beschlossen klar ist wer kommt der soll
sein Talent voll einbringen unsere
Wirtschaft voranbringen und auch
deutsche oder deutscher werden wenn die
Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind dass es
eine bleibekultur die wir brauchen das
gehen wir jetzt gemeinsam in der
Ampelkoalition an vielen Dank
dr Gottfried Curio hat das Wort für die
AFD
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die Voraussetzungen für den Erwerb der
deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft werden
komplett geschleift
Integrationsanforderungen runter sprach
Beherrschung runter staatsbürgerliche
Grundkenntnisse Fristen fast halbiert
dabei ist die Gemeinde Zielgruppe weder
ökonomisch noch kulturell irgendwie
integriert gerade das ist aber leider
der Grund die Anforderung zu Aufenthalt
zu Staatsbürgerschaft immer wieder
abzusenken überproportional bei
sozialhilfeempfang bei Kriminalität
bildungsversagen all diese Probleme der
Zuwanderer sollen mit einem Handstreich
vertuscht werden indem deren Zahlen in
die deutsche Gesamtbevölkerung
eingemeindet werden dabei wollen laut
einer Umfrage zwei Drittel der Deutschen
keine Vereinfachung der Einführung aber
mit Brecht fragt sich die Regierung wer
es nicht am einfachsten man löste das
Volk auf und wählte ein anderes die
Ampel macht damit jetzt ernst sie will
end Fakten schaffen und mit denen seit
2015 importierten und alimentierten
Ausländern auch endlich ihre Wahlen
Steuern schon nach fünf oder gar drei
Jahren bekommen Sie die
Staatsbürgerschaft der Sprach- und
Einbürgerungstest wird für die die schon
lange da sind mit deren
Deutschkenntnissen man offenbar lieber
nicht rechnen möchte einfach gestrichen
Einordnung in die deutsche
Lebensverhältnisse kein Thema mehr
islamische viel eher kein Problem aber
eine Islamisierung findet ja nicht statt
armes Deutschland meine Damen und Herren
Merkel hat 2015 gesät jetzt ist
Erntezeit wenn genügend Neubürger
geschaffen worden sind nimmt die
entmündung der deutschen Fahrt auf die
deutsche Wahlbevölkerung soll durch ein
Heer ausländischer Sozialhilfeempfänger
gesteuert werden erst wird die halbe
Welt her gelockt durch überhöhte
Sozialleistungen hier auf der tränenden
Schiene Flucht verkauft dann bekommen
alle unberechtigten die
Aufenthaltserlaubnis als Chance dann
rein per Zeitablauf den deutschen Pass
das ganze ist ein Staatsstreich in der
wählerdemographie meine Damen und Herren
Ministerin ferser gibt vor bei den
passwollegeber ein starkes Bekenntnis zu
Deutschland ab sage JA zu freiheitlicher
Gesellschaft Grundgesetz und
Gleichberechtigung nein sagt er nicht er
nimmt vielmehr das Wahlrecht um das Land
zu verändern und als Zeichen das
ausführliche Integration gerade keine
Voraussetzung mehr ist dass vielmehr das
Wahlrecht jetzt schlicht kurzfristig
ersetzen werden kann ist das Ganze
förmlich ein
antiintegrationsgesetz meine Damen und
Herren dabei sollte er mit dem Wahlrecht
die Steuerung des Landes in die Hand
bekommt eigentlich ein Demokratie Profi
sein aber die Leute kommen aus einem
politkulturellen Umfeld dem unsere
Vorstellungen völlig fremd sind die
werden diese Ideen ganz sicher nicht in
fünf oder drei Jahren verinnerlichen
wenn überhaupt in Wahrheit muss es doch
umgekehrt sein erst muss eine wirkliche
Integration erfolgen auch als Bemühung
um die Staatsbürgerschaft nicht
umgekehrt ohne
Schweiß kein Preis sie verschleudern
erst den Pass an ungenügend inspirierte
das ist ein Aufbauprogramm für
Parallelgesellschaften meine Damen und
Herren und dementsprechend können
irgendwelche Gründe für ein schnelleren
Erwerb der Staatsbürgerschaft auch
überhaupt nicht benannt werden jetzt
schnell einfach alle deutschen nennen zu
wollen zeugt nur von Missachtung des
eigenen von Identifikation mit der
Nation ihren Werten Geschichte Kultur
kein Wort im chorvertrag will man mit
einer Kampagne den Erwerb der
Staatsbürgerschaft extra bewerben
offenbar ist das Bedürfnis auf Seiten
der koop-parteien größer als bei den
eigentlichen Adressaten es geht um
vermutete Wählerstimmen für die eigene
Partei dafür soll das Schicksal
Deutschlands werden vaterlandslose
Gesellen wie sie im Buch stehen meine
Damen und Herren der Kanzler klagt 9
Millionen Bürger leben und arbeiten hier
ohne die Staatsbürgerschaft die Wahrheit
von knapp 12 Millionen Arbeiten
viereinhalb aber nicht die Quantität
geht fehlt auch die Qualität
eingebürgert werden sollte doch der der
über ein Identifikation mit Deutschland
verfügt was tut man dafür man macht den
Doppel zur Regel das glatt im Gegenteil
das meinte das Grundgesetz nicht mit dem
Staatsvolk allererst als Ursprung und
Träger der Staatlichkeit der Nation
diese Pläne sind schlicht
verfassungswidrig und die FDP im
Umfragetief die das im kohervertrag
schon abgelegt hat simuliert jetzt
plötzlich Bauchschmerzen aber nur der
Zeitpunkt passe nicht den Inhalt finden
die okay meine Damen und Herren seit
2005 haben wir eine nette Auswanderung
der deutschen aber für Zuwanderung wird
getrommelt Bevölkerungsaustausch pur der
häufigste Kommentar unter Artikeln zur
einwirkungsoffensive ist ich wandere aus
kein Wunder wenn einem das Land unter
den Füßen weggezogen werden soll aber
der Kanzler weiß zum berührendsten was
erlebt habe gehörten die
Einbürgerungsfeier war aller Argumente
in der Sache verfällt man auf so eine
schmunzette es wird einem übel wenn man
von so viel Ergriffenheit hört was es
schon bedeutet habe einen Brief zu
bekommen vom Bürgermeister sie sollten
sich überlegen die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zu wählen er meint
natürlich die SPD zu wählen fakt ist je
mehr Ausländer wandern und eingebürgert
werden desto mehr deutscher wandern aus
weil die Steuern zu hoch sind den Spaß
noch zu finanzieren das ganze ist ein
einziges Fachkräfte vertreibungsgesetz
das ist die Ampel für Ausländer aber
keiner muss sie wählen denn es gibt ja
noch die Alternative für deutsche ich
danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
der Kollege auch mit nuripo hat das Wort
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen super Bündnis
90 die Grünen ist
einer der beiden Parteivorsitzenden
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich weiß nicht ob sich jemand noch einen
Vertrag von Aachen erinnert da ging es
um die Vertiefung der
deutsch-französischen Freundschaft die
AFD hat uns damals erzählt darüber wird
sich Deutschland auflösen ich weiß nicht
ob sich jemand erinnert an den Global
Compact von Migration wir werden alle
sterben haben sie gesagt nichts davon
ist passiert jetzt geht die nächste
Geschichte sie erzählen einfach den
Weltuntergang herbei wollen die Leute
verunsichern ich kann Ihnen versichern
die Deutschen sind zu schlau um auf
diesen Schwachsinn rein zu fallen
was
das ist nicht neu dass das die AFD macht
es nicht neu was aber neu und zu ich
gebe zu befremdliches ist das eine
Klaviatur dem bisschen ähnlich klingt
und ich hoffe dass es nur so klingt
jetzt von der Union an dieser Stelle
gerade auftaucht ich verstehe es nicht
ich verstehe es nicht wir erinnern uns
alle zumindest wir älteren erinnern uns
an der Sommermärchen 2006 in Deutschland
so viele Klischees über unser Land sind
beseitigt worden und zwar im Bild dieser
Landes draußen in der Welt wir waren
gastfreundschaftlich wir waren modern
wir waren weltoffen so wie es dieses
Land und so wird dieses Land auch
draußen gesehen und ich kann nur davor
warnen mit diesem Bild zu spielen das
wäre nicht verantwortlich aber es geht
nicht nur es geht nicht nur ums Bild
es geht auch um gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt und es geht um unsere
Wirtschaft und ich verstehe ernsthaft
nicht was was hier passiert sie reden ja
auch mit der mit der Wirtschaft wir
reden viel mit den Unternehmerinnen
Unternehmern ich habe das Gefühl dass
vielleicht auch mal zugehört werden soll
ihrerseits an dieser Stelle wenn man mit
ihnen redet da gibt es drei Baustellen
es gibt drei Baustellen wo der Schuh
drückt es Struktur bei den
Energiepreisen ja der die billigen oder
die kostengünstigen Erneuerbaren sind
nicht ausgebaut sondern blockiert worden
von der Uni und die letzten Jahre wir
bauen sie gerade aus es geht um
Rohstoffe und Lieferketten wir sind
einseitig abhängig wir diversifizieren
gerade mit großer Geschwindigkeit und es
geht um Arbeitskräfte es fehlen an ganz
vielen Orten Arbeitskräfte und deshalb
macht diese Koalition Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz und das ist nicht
die einzige Lösung des wissen wir das
ist nicht das Thema aber wir machen
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz wir
machen einen Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz
und damit ist auch da auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt darauf vorangeht und wir
wachen die Perspektive für diejenigen
die im internationalen Wettbewerb um die
ersten Köpfe schauen wo sie hin wollen
auch für auch besser für Deutschland das
ist doch das was wir gerade veranstalten
die BlueCard ist auch deswegen nicht
vorangekommen weil das dieser
Perspektive nicht gegeben hat sie machen
Identitätspolitik wir machen
Wirtschaftspolitik sie machen Populismus
wir machen Integrationsarbeit und so ist
die Arbeitsteilung in diesen Zeiten und
das ist bedauerlich
und die die Lautstärke lässt ein
vermuten dass es ja eigentlich um
Zerrissenheit geht im Umgang mit dem
Erbe von Angela Merkel dafür kann das
Land aber nicht da setzen sich zusammen
und überlegen was sie machen sollen und
ich bin dankbar und froh und ich weiß
dass das mutig ist ich habe selber auch
schon mal gegen meine eigene Fraktion
gestimmt aber wenn man schaut wie viele
Leute aus ihrer Fraktion die nicht
irgendwelche Leute sind die im Kabinett
Merkel gesessen haben nun und andere und
und auch andere gewichtige Positionen in
der Union vertreten haben jetzt für
unser Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz stimmen
wollen dann sieht man doch dass es
eigentlich um die inneren Zerwürfnisse
der Union geht dabei müssen sie sehr
dabei müssen sie ja gar nicht aufhören
Rita Süßmuth hat die hat damals die
Kommission geleitet die gesagt hat wir
brauchen Punktesystem und dieses
Baustein Einwanderung ist ein asset beim
beim Standort Deutschland hören Sie doch
auf BDI
bdr.dhk oder die Wirtschaftsweisen sie
werden Ihnen alle dasselbe sein aber ich
will noch eine Sache wirklich versuchen
zu verstehen ich verstehe diese Sache
einfach schlicht nicht wenn ihr von
verarschen gesprochen wird bei Leuten
die nur überhaupt in Frage kommen wenn
sie ihren lebensaufnahme selber
verdienen können beispielsweise
ich frage das wirklich ich frage mich
dass das einer der nicht hier heute
stehen könnte wenn es die mehr
Staatlichkeit in Härtefällen nicht geben
könnte in diesem Land eine Gesetzgebung
die sie heute sagen die wird doch
reichen die sie damals im übrigen
komplett bekämpft haben aber ich frage
mich warum haben Leute weniger Rechte
wenn andere mehr Rechte haben das ist
doch das was sie hier so gerieren hier
eine leiterte das macht aber überhaupt
keinen Sinn das macht einfach keinen
Sinn das einzige die Sie mir erklären
kann ist eine loyalitätsparanoia aber
dahinter ist halt einfach nicht diese
loyalitätsparanoia braucht es nicht ich
bitte wirklich wirklich flehendlich
darum lassen sie uns diese Debatten
lassen die Krisen sie zu groß dieses
Land hat immense Herausforderungen und
wir müssen an dieser Stelle
zusammenstehen und alles dafür tun um
nicht noch weiter zu spalten es ist so
dringend notwendig dass wir und dafür
strecken wir die Hand auch aus sachlich
und normal miteinander solche Debatten
führen rational und beispielsweise für
die Frage was ist gut für den
Arbeitsmarkt das sollten wir zusammen
tun im Pole unseres Landes herzlichen
Dank
Vorsitzender von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
unter anderem mit einem Rückblick auf
die Arbeit von Rita süßmut die war von
2000 bis 2001 im Juli Vorsitzende der
unabhängigen Kommission Zuwanderung so
lange wird über dieses Thema schon
gestritten und davor ja auch schon
Janine Wissler ist am Pult auch sie ist
ein Parteivorsitzender allerdings der
linken und jetzt ihr Beitrag
Teil der Gesellschaft aber eben nicht
vollständig sie dürfen nicht wählen und
nicht zur Wahlen antreten weil sie keine
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft haben ihr
Leben wird bestimmt durch politische
Entscheidungen an denen sie nicht durch
Wahlen mitwirken können vor 60 Jahren
kamen die ersten Gastarbeiter nach
Deutschland ihnen wurde das Wahlrecht
vorenthalten und auch die Anerkennung
ihrer Lebensleistung Deutschland ist ein
Einwanderungsland und diese Realität
muss ich endlich auch im Wahl und im
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht widerspiegeln
im Jahr 1972 lag der Anteil der
Wahlberechtigten an der
Gesamtbevölkerung bei 91%. seitdem sinkt
der Anteil stetig 2021 lag ja nur noch
bei 73%. das ist ein Problem für die
Demokratie und hinter diesen Zahlen
stehen Menschen die ausgegrenzt werden
als Einwohner zweiter Klasse die
einbowlungsquote ist im europäischen
Vergleich niedrig denn eine Einbürgerung
ist mit vielen Hürden Kosten und
Zeitaufwand verbunden das schreckt viele
Menschen ab überhaupt einen Antrag zu
stellen und deshalb begrüßen wir dass
die bundesinnenministerin eine
Erleichterung von Einbürgerung
angekündigt hat wie er auch im
Koalitionsvertrag das ehrampel
versprochen wurde wer schon viele Jahre
in Deutschland lebt der soll nach fünf
statt bisher nach acht Jahren
eingebürgert werden können und die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft soll
einfacher werden gut so diese Reform ist
lange überfällig um allen dauerhaft hier
lebenden Menschen Partizipation zu
ermöglichen meine Damen und
und was macht die Union sie erklärt die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft werde
entwertet und verramscht wenn sie ohne
Leistung vergeben werden was ist das
denn für eine bekloppte Argumentation
wie kann denn etwas verranzt werden was
hunderttausende Menschen jedes Jahr ohne
jede Leistung und ohne eigenes Zutun
bekommen nämlich nur durch Geburt weil
ihre Eltern zufällig Deutsche sind was
haben Sie denn für ihren deutschen Pass
geleistet Herr Merz genauso viel wie ich
nämlich gar nichts genauso wie die
meisten Deutschen
es ist reiner Zufall es ist
spermienlotterie in welchem Land und in
welcher Familie man geboren wird warum
sollte man also dieses Dokument und die
damit verbundenen Rechte so vielen
Menschen vorenthalten die genauso hier
geboren wurden die genauso hier leben
und arbeiten wie alle anderen
CDU und CSU Spalten die Menschen und sie
spielen sie gegeneinander aus als würde
auch nur irgendein deutscher irgendetwas
dadurch verlieren dass jemand anders
eingebürgert wird der Pass wird ja das
hat niemandem weggenommen nicht der Pass
wird entwertet sie entwerten Menschen
durch solche Debatten meine Damen und
Herren und ich erinnere mich gut an 1999
an Roland Koch an die Kampagne gegen die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft als Menschen
zum cdu-wahlkampfstand gekommen sind und
gefragt haben wo sie gegen Ausländer
unterschreiben können die CDU hat damals
ganz bewusst rassistische Vorteile
geführt und sie haben mit dieser
Kampagne großen Schaden angerichtet sie
haben das Klima vergiftet und viele
Menschen zutiefst verletzt
so bereitet man den Nährboden zur Hass
und Gewalt auf Kosten derer die
alltäglich von Rassismus betroffen sind
und die Gefahr von rechts die wächst
doch die Morde des NSU Halle Hanau der
Mordan Walter Lübke jeden alle paar Tage
brennt eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft wer in
einer solchen Situation gegen
Einwanderer polymisiert und Stimmung
macht der weiß doch ganz genau was er
tut und sie sprechen ganz im afd-slang
von der Einwanderung in Sozialsysteme
von sozialtourismus und einer
inflationären Vergabe von Hessen das ist
ein gefährlicher Unsinn und das ist ein
Schlag ins Gesicht der vielen Menschen
die in den letzten Jahrzehnten einen
wichtigen Beitrag zum Wohlstand dieses
Landes geleistet haben und an den hohen
einbürgerungshürden gescheitert sind
meine Damen und Herren
ich fordere die CDU
und die CSU und uns besondere die Hessen
CDU auf dringend auf nicht erneut eine
rassistische Kampagne zur
Staatsbürgerschaft zu führen und obwohl
sie bekanntermaßen Teil der
Ampelkoalition ist distanziert sich die
afdp jetzt auch von der geplanten Reform
wie schon beim Bürgergeld fungiert die
FDP als Verstärker von März und Söder
auf Kosten der Menschen die ausgegrenzte
diskriminiert werden ob aufgrund von
Armut oder ihrer Migrationsgeschichte
oder aufgrund von beidem die
angekündigten Erleichterung müssen
schnell umgesetzt werden sie müssen
barrierefrei sein und unabhängig vom
sozialen Status die zuständigen Behörden
müssen entsprechend ausgestattet werden
und wir werden alle Schritte
unterstützen die Menschen demokratische
Teilhabe ermöglichen lassen Sie mich zu
dem Schluss zum Schluss kurz zitieren
aus dem flüchtlingsgesprächen von
Berthold Brecht der Pass ist der edelste
Teil von einem Menschen er kommt auch
nicht auf so einfache Weise zustande wie
ein Mensch ein Mensch kann überall
zustande kommen auf die königste Art und
ohne gescheiten Grund aber einen Pass
niemals dafür wird er auch anerkannt
wenn er gut ist während ein Mensch noch
so gut sein kann und doch nicht
anerkannt wird für uns zählt der Mensch
Janine Wissler endet mit einem
brech-zitat in dieser aktuellen Stunde
des Deutschen Bundestags die auf Antrag
der Unionsfraktion zustande gekommen ist
und in der es um Pläne der
Bundesregierung zur schnelleren
Einbürgerung geht da gab es
differenzierte Äußerungen zu unter
anderem aus den Rhein der FDP und unter
anderem von Konstantin Kuhle dem
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
in unserem Land umsieht wenn man mit
Arbeitgebern wenn man mit Unternehmen
spricht dann merkt man sofort der Mangel
an Arbeitskräften er ist mit Händen
zugreifen und wir werden als alternde
Gesellschaft diesen Mangel an
Arbeitskräften nur in den Griff bekommen
wenn wir auf Einwanderung setzen das
sagen Ihnen alle Experten und das sagt
Ihnen auch die Wirtschaft selbst ich
will mal vortragen was der deutsche
Industrie und handelskammertag an diesem
Montag in dieser Woche in der wir diese
Debatte hier führen gegenüber der
Deutschen Presseagentur gesagt hat ich
zitiere viele Unternehmen setzen darauf
dass der Zug von Fachkräften aus
Drittstaaten weiter erleichtert wird
auch in der aktuellen Krise ist der
Fachkräftemangel für die Unternehmen
nach den Energiekosten das zweitgrößte
Geschäftsrisiko Zitat Ende ich will
ihnen etwas sagen meine Damen und Herren
es ist ganz normal dass sich in einer
Koalition mit so unterschiedlichen
Partnern wie Grünen und SPD und FDP dass
sich die Leute da auch mal in die Wolle
kriegen aber wenn wir eine Verantwortung
haben wenn wir eine Verantwortung haben
nachdem nach 16 Jahren die Union nicht
mehr den Innenminister stellt dann ist
es den Mehltau in der deutschen
Einwanderungspolitik zu beseitigen und
ein Einwanderungsgesetz zu beschließen
dass diese Erwartungen erfüllt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dabei sind
wir doch auf einem guten Weg dabei sind
wir auf einem guten Weg wir haben
gestern im Kabinett Eckpunkte zur
Einwanderung aus Drittstaaten in den
Arbeitsmarkt beschlossen Erleichterung
für Menschen mit praktischen
Berufserfahrung eine Ausdehnung der Blue
Card einer Ausdehnung der
westbalkanregelung und die Einführung
einer chancenkarte mit Punktesystem nach
dem Vorbild erfolgreicher
Einwanderungsländer wie Kanada und
dieses Gesetz werden wir beschließen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union sie werden es bekämpfen das können
sie machen aber dann seien sie auch so
offen und sagen dass sie damit Politik
gegen die Interessen der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft und gegen die Sicherung
des deutschen Wohlstands machen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
wir Freie Demokraten sind davon
überzeugt dass dieses
Einwanderungsgesetz eines der zentralen
Reformprojekte der Ampelkoalition ist
und deswegen muss dieses
Einwanderungsgesetz auch zügig
beschlossen werden und deswegen wäre es
verfehlt das Thema Einwanderung bereits
jetzt mit dem Thema ein bürgerung zu
vermengen denn unser Einwanderungsgesetz
es muss eingebettet sein in ein
migrationspolitisches Gesamtkonzept und
dieses migrationspolitische
Gesamtkonzept das lässt sich
zusammenfassen mit der Formel mehr
reguläre Migration weniger irreguläre
Migration liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn wir in der Gesellschaft dauerhaft
die Akzeptanz für Migration und auch für
das neue Einwanderungsgesetz erhalten
wollen dann muss Einwanderung geordnet
und regelbasiert erfolgen und wir haben
dazu verschiedene Maßnahmen vereinbart
in der Koalition unter anderem die
Beschleunigung von Asylverfahren und
asylgerichtsverfahren die wir schon an
diesem Freitag beschließen werden steht
aber noch mehr im Koalitionsvertrag
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen steht
auch eine rückführungsoffensive im
Koalitionsvertrag und es steht der
Abschluss von migrationsabkommen mit den
hauptherkunftsstaaten im
Koalitionsvertrag und hier sage ich ganz
deutlich an die Adresse der
Bundesregierung muss mehr passieren
damit wir gesamtgesellschaftlich auch
die Akzeptanz für Migrationspolitik
erhalten werden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Teil des
migrationspolitischen Gesamtkonzepts der
Ampelkoalition ist auch eine Reform des
Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts denn wir
wollen dass Menschen die sich in
Deutschland integrieren schneller
deutsche Staatsangehörige werden können
zu den Kriterien für eine Einbürgerung
gehört schon heute dass die Menschen
ihren eigenen Lebensunterhalt sichern
können und an dieser Stelle darf und
wird es auch keinen Rabatt auf die
Verleihung der deutschen
Staatsangehörigkeit geben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aber es wäre
doch absurd wenn diese Generation an
politischen Verantwortungsträgern die
Fehler wiederholt die im Umgang mit den
Gastarbeitern in Deutschland gemacht
worden sind ich finde es würde los ich
finde es daneben dass die dritte
Generation der Gastarbeiter Nachkommen
die seit drei Generationen in diesem
Land Steuern zahlen immer noch keine
deutschen Staatsangehörigen sind und das
werden wir ändern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
schon heute
schon heute behalten übrigens 60 Prozent
der Menschen die eingebürgert werden
ihren ursprünglichen Pass wir haben also
bereits eine Hinwendung zur
Mehrstaatlichkeit zur Wahrheit gehört
aber auch dazu dass in traditionellen
erfolgreichen Einwanderungsländern wie
Kanada wie Australien Menschen schon
innerhalb kürzester Zeit nach wenigen
Generationen nicht mehr Mexikaner nicht
mehr Briten nicht mehr Inder sind
sondern ausschließlich Australier und
Kanadier und deswegen werbe ich auch
innerhalb der Opposition innerhalb der
Opposition und innerhalb der Koalition
dafür dass wir uns damit beschäftigen
wie sich auch die Einbürgerung einbetten
kann in ein Gesamtkonzept der
Migrationspolitik und wie Einwanderung
und Einbürgerung zusammen gedacht werden
können und ihr braucht vor allen Dingen
die richtige Reihenfolge liebe meine
Damen und Herren
ich komme zum Schluss und will einmal
sagen viele wissen das ja dass ich aus
Niedersachsen komme und wir hatten in
Niedersachsen mal einen tollen
Ministerpräsidenten namens David
McAllister David McAllister war nicht
nur deutscher Staatsbürger der wird
McAllister war auch britischer
Staatsbürger ich frage mich was hat die
cdu/csu-fraktion eigentlich gegen David
McAllister wir kommen zum Ende ein
toller ministerprä
sident und ich finde dass das nichts mit
seiner Staatsangehörigkeit zu tun hat
und deswegen sage ich an die Adresse der
Union ich wünsche mir mehr leben
McAllister und weniger Roland Koch Herr
Kollege
Konstantin coole mit einem interessanten
Beispiel aus der Praxis der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland was für
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaften angeht das
ist ja hier auch ein großes Thema in
dieser Debatte ganz interessant noch
nebenbei das Vorhaben zum Thema
Einbürgerung ist bislang am wenigsten
vorangedienen in der Ampel Koalition da
gibt es lediglich in Anführungszeichen
bisher das Papier aus dem
Innenministerium alle anderen Vorhaben
rund um Migration und zugewanderung sind
schon wesentlich weiter Thorsten frei
CDU CSU-Fraktion und
ja diese Bemerkung habe ich an exakt
diejenigen gerichtet die jetzt so
applaudieren weil wissen Sie wenn Sie
eine grundlegende Veränderung einen
Paradigmenwechsel im deutschen
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht wollen dadurch
dass sie die Mehrstaatlichkeit generell
annehmen und hinnehmen dann können sie
das nicht machen ohne dass eine
öffentliche Debatte geführt wird dann
können sie nicht glauben dass wir
darüber nicht reden wollen sie führen
eine Debatte sie machen Vorschläge die
60 70 Prozent der Menschen in unserem
Land nicht wollen und wenn es so ist
dann müssen Sie diese Debatte mit uns
führen und sie dürfen sie nicht so
führen dass sie jeden der andere Meinung
ist als sie als spalterisch als
populistisch als rassistisch oder wie
auch immer abtun das ist keine ehrliche
Debatte und um ehrlich zu sein das ist
auch unterhalb ihres Niveaus
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
glaube man muss einfach auch der
Klarheit wegen sagen wenn Sie
grundsätzlich die Mehrstaatlichkeit im
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht hinnehmen
möchten dann hat es weitreichende
Änderungen dann hat es weitreichende
Änderungen nicht nur für die
Zusammensetzung des Staatsvolkes dann
hat es weitreichende Änderungen
beispielsweise für das für die
Aufenthaltstitel und das System dort
insgesamt denn wenn es nach fünf Jahren
die deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit geben
soll dann hat es natürlich Auswirkungen
beispielsweise auch auf die Frage wann
wird ein Daueraufenthaltsrecht gegeben
wann werden andere Aufenthaltstitel
erteilt das hat weitreichende
Konsequenzen und darüber muss man
miteinander diskutieren und Sie haben
beispielsweise Vorschläge gemacht für
ein chanceneinwanderungsgesetz wo es
letztlich darum geht dass Menschen die
abgelehnte Asylbewerber sind die seit
Jahren nicht aus unserem Land ausreißen
dass die letztlich auch noch für
prämiert werden wenn sie nicht dazu
beitragen über ihre Identität Auskunft
zu geben also es geht am Ende des Tages
auch darum dass der Rechtsstaat sich
selber ernst nimmt lassen Sie mich eines
noch mal ganz klar sagen natürlich ist
Deutschland ein Einwanderungsland und
deswegen finde ich darf man die Dinge
auch nicht durcheinander bringen wir
werden um Frauen und Männer aus allen
Teilen der Welt die unsere Werte teilen
die hier gemeinsame Ziele mit uns
verwirklichen möchten die hier arbeiten
möchten und ihr Glück finden möchten es
ist übrigens nicht so dass sie dafür die
Voraussetzungen erfunden hätten 2019
haben wir ein Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz gemacht ja und wenn
sie mal ehrlich sind wenn sie mal
ehrlich sind sind die Probleme dieses
Gesetzes nicht das Gesetz sondern das
Problem im Bereich der Fachkräfte
Einwanderung ist beispielsweise dass
unsere Konsulat Abteilungen ein Jahr
teilweise brauchen bis Termine genehmigt
werden und zum anderen auch die
Anerkennung von Berufsabschlüssen nicht
so funktioniert wie wir uns das
vorstellen könnten das sind die
tatsächlichen Probleme die man dabei
lösen muss und lassen sie mich zum
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht eines sagen
die Staatsangehörigkeit führt letztlich
dazu dass Bürger untereinander in einer
ganz besonderen Verbindung stehen das
hat was mit Identifikation zu tun
darüber haben wir gesprochen und jetzt
ist es so der Staat führt und die
Staatsangehörigkeit des führt zu rechten
und das führt auch zu Verpflichtungen
und eine Staatsangehörigkeit zu haben
ist eine relativ einfache Angelegenheit
wenn der Staat im Gewand eines
Sozialstaates daherkommt im Gewand eines
demokratischen Rechtsstaates wenn er bei
konsular Angelegenheiten im Ausland
hilft aber der Staat kommt auch um
beispielsweise zu fordern dass er von
den Bürgern ja nicht nur das Steuern
bezahlt werden das Eigentum zur
Verfügung gestellt werden muss dass er
mit Menschenleben verteidigt werden muss
und deshalb ist es immer eine
gesamthafte Betrachtung die man hier
anstellen muss ich will ihnen eines
sagen es ist richtig die
einbürgerungsquote in Deutschland ist
nicht hoch aber so zu tun als ob die
Tatsache dass nicht jeder die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft haben kann heute das
Hindernis wäre ist schlicht falsch
schauen Sie sich mal in Europa um in den
Niederlanden haben wir eine vier bis
fünf Mal höhere einbürgerungsquote
tatsächlich gibt es dort aber faktisch
die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft nicht
die gibt es übrigens auch nicht den
Ländern wie Dänemark und Österreich und
es führte zu auch in Litauen nicht diese
Länder haben keine Integrationsprobleme
wer hat Integrationsprobleme Länder wie
Großbritannien Frankreich und Schweden
die Länder die die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft haben das eine hängt
mit dem anderen zusammen sie bauen einen
propans auf das ist nicht richtig und
eines müssen sie sich gefallen lassen
man kann Meinungen in der Demokratie
vertreten aber sie lassen andere
Positionen nicht zu sie sind noch nicht
einmal bereit ernsthaft zu reden ohne
hier mit Polemik um sich zu werfen
Thorsten Frey ist der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
cdu/csu-fraktion und der erste Satz den
er gesagt hat vorhin bei in seinem
Beitrag war diese Debatte hat keinen
guten Ton und das hat die heftigen
Reaktionen in der
ampelkoalitions ausgelöst bzw in deren
rein nächster Redner in dieser aktuellen
Stunde des Bundestags wird Mahmut
Özdemir sein Parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär bei der Bundesministerin
des Innern und für Heimat
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich glaube es
ist gut zur Halbzeit nach dieser Rede
befördern zu wollen dass wir in der
anstehenden Diskussion um die Reform des
Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts auf einer
Sache und Fachebene zu bleiben und auf
Basis der Fakten weiter zu unterhalten
aber eine Mahnung kann ich mir nicht
ersparen im zusammenhangwertungen wie
faramschen
in Zusammenhang mit dem
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht also das was
unser Staatsvolk definiert und bildet zu
verwenden halte ich für schändlich und
es kommt aus der und es kommt aus der
gleichen Schublade wie sozialtourismus
und diese Schublade sollte man zulassen
die Fakten wir verlangen weiterhin ein
qualifiziertes Aufenthaltsrecht es sind
ein Bekenntnis zur freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung des
Grundgesetzes und eine
loyalitätserklärung abzugeben Identität
und bestehende Staatsangehörigkeit
müssen geklärt sein der Lebensunterhalt
muss gesichert sein mündliche und
schriftliche Deutschkenntnisse müssen
durch eine Sprachprüfung belegt sein nur
hier machen wir eine gezielte Ausnahme
zu der ich gleich noch mal kommen werde
es müssen Kenntnisse der deutschen
rechts- und Gesellschaftsordnung
nachgewiesen sein und auch künftig darf
eine Einbürgerung bei Bestehen einer
mehr Ehe nicht vollzogen werden und auch
nicht wenn die Gleichberechtigung von
Mann und Frau nicht akzeptiert wird wir
ersetzen damit den unklaren Begriff der
Einordnung in die deutschen
Lebensverhältnisse durch klare Kriterien
Deutschland ist längst ein
Einwanderungsland geworden Ende 2021 da
helfe ich auch gerne mit Fakten lebten
rund 72,4 Millionen Menschen mit
deutscher und rund 10,7 Millionen mit
ausländischer Staatsangehörigkeit in
Deutschland von denen sich rund 5,7
Millionen Menschen bereits mehr oder
mindestens zehn Jahre in Deutschland
auffielen dies hat zur Folge dass ein
zahlenmäßig bedeutender
Bevölkerungsteil der auf Dauer in
Deutschland lebt und hier seine Heimat
gefunden hat von Rechten und Pflichten
eines Bürgers gegenüber dem Staat
ausgeschlossen bleibt für den
Zusammenhalt in Deutschland ist aber
entscheidend
dass auch diejenigen die längst Teil
unserer Gesellschaft geworden sind
mitgestalten und mitentscheiden dürfen
dazu gehört vor allen Dingen die
politische Teilnahme durch das aktive
und passive Wahlrecht Rechte die mir
persönlich trotz meiner Geburt in
Deutschland ohne eine Einbürgerung
verwehrt geblieben werden
fakt ist dass Deutschland bei den
Einbürgerungen im Vergleich zu anderen
europäischen Staaten nicht gut dasteht
die durchschnittliche einbürgerungsrate
liegt nach der letzten Erhebung von
Eurosat deutlich unter dem Durchschnitt
der Europäischen Union unser Ziel ist es
die Missstände zu beseitigen die sich
teilweise schon über Jahrzehnte
aufgestaut haben auch teilweise unter
einer sehr
fragwürdigen bmi-führung wir können
nicht an Rahmenbedingungen für die
Einbürgerung festhalten die heute
gesellschaftlich und politisch keine
Billigung mehr finden durch die Mehrheit
das hat die Bundestagswahl das hat die
Bundestagswahl sehr deutlich gezeigt
das ist das Ergebnis der Bundestagswahl
sie müssen auch mal gesellschaftliche
und politische Realitäten irgendwann
akzeptieren also ich sehe den
Phantomschmerz aber kann ich Ihnen auch
nicht mehr helfen der Erwerb der Erwerb
und die Annahme der deutschen
Staatsangehörigkeit ist das stärkste
Bekenntnis zu Deutschland denn wir
Deutsche oder deutsche Staatsbürger
werden will sagt ja zu einem Leben in
einer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft zur
Achtung des Grundgesetzes zur
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und zur
Gleichberechtigung von Frauen und
Männern dieses Bekenntnis ist wichtiger
als die Frage ob jemand eine oder
mehrere Staatsangehörigkeiten besitzt
insofern verweise ich Sie darauf dass es
mehr Staatlichkeit heißt und nicht
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft die
Verpflichtung zur Aufgabe
die Verpflichtung zur Aufgabe ihrer
herkunftsstaatsangehörigkeit stellt für
viele
einbürgerungsinteressierte ein Hindernis
da sie fühlen sich Deutschland zugehörig
wollen aber den Bezug zu ihrem
Herkunftsland nicht völlig verlieren der
Grundsatz zur Vermeidung der
Mehrstaatlichkeit entspricht schon seit
langem nicht mehr der tatsächlichen
Einbürgerungspraxis im Jahr 2021 hat die
mehrstarterquote bei den Einbürgerungen
nun schon 69 Prozent erreicht der
Grundsatz der Vermeidung von
Mehrstaatlichkeit ist damit schon lange
nicht mehr enorm sondern die Ausnahme
das sind die Fakten
wir werden deshalb wir werden deshalb
Mehrstaatlichkeit daher künftig generell
zulassen merken Sie sich bitte diesen
Begriff mit anderen Begriffen haben sie
eher Probleme dadurch wird auch die
dadurch wird auch die optionsregelung
beim geburtserwerb vollständig entfallen
künftig werden alle in Deutschland
geborenen Kinder ausländischer Eltern
bei denen mindestens ein Elternteil seit
mehr als fünf Jahren rechtmäßig und mit
unbefristeten Aufenthaltsrecht in
Deutschland lebt die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit und die
Staatsangehörigkeit ihrer Eltern
erhalten und vor allen Dingen dauerhaft
behalten sie müssen sich nicht mehr für
oder gegen
Eigenanteil oder ein Teil ihrer
Identität entscheiden und das ist längst
überfällig liebe Kolleginnen
eine schnellere Möglichkeit zur
Einbürgerung ist ein wesentliches
Element auch einer guten
einbürgerungskultur die Teilhabe an
Entscheidungen schafft Menschen mit
Einwanderungsgeschichte die ein
qualifiziertes Aufenthaltsrecht haben
sollen daher bereits nach fünf Jahren
die Möglichkeit haben auch eingebürgert
zu werden und ich frage warum sollten
diejenigen die hier bereits verwurzelt
sind alle Einbürgerungsvoraussetzungen
erfüllen auch weiter warten müssen wer
zusätzliche Leistungen erbringt kann
diese vorenthaltsdauer auch noch mal
erheblich verkürzen bei der
Modernisierung unseres
staatsangehörigkeitsrechtes soll auch
die Lebensleistung der Angehörigen der
sogenannten Gastarbeitergeneration
berücksichtigt werden das ist die
Generation die wir bis heute auf den
Stuben der Ausländerämter verweisen wenn
Sie einen neuen Pass beantragen und ihre
Aufenthaltserlaubnis übertragen lassen
müssen wir schicken sie zu
ausländerämtern lassen sie wochenlang
lassen sie Monate lang darauf warten
dass sie eigentlich eine Staatsleistung
bekommen die ihn schon längst angedeiht
hätte werden müssen
das ist auch eine Frage des Respektes
dass wir diesen Menschen auch diesen
notwendigen Respekt mit diesem Gesetz
zollen sie haben in der Vergangenheit
keine oder nur wenig
teilhabeangebote erhalten deshalb werden
wir für Sie bei der Einbürgerung
Erleichterung beim Sprachnachweis
schaffen und auch auf den einbürungstest
verzichten
diese einbürgerungserleichterung sollen
auch für alle Personen gelten die das
gesetzliche Renteneintrittsalter also
das 67 lebensjahr vollendet haben damit
auch Sie eine realistische Möglichkeit
zur Einbürgerung haben mit der Hinnahme
der Mehrstaatlichkeit werden wir ein
Paradigmenwechsel Einleiten der längst
überfällig ist zugleich werden wir mit
der Modernisierung des
staatsangehörigkeitsrechtes die
Einbürgerung einfacher und attraktiver
machen die sind aber nicht die einzigen
Gründe warum wir ein moderneres
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht schaffen
wollen wir müssen das
Staatsangehörigkeit auch recht
reformieren um Deutschland Zukunft
festzumachen wir haben es gerade in der
Debatte schon teilweise gehört die
Wirtschaft mahnt immer wieder an dass
der Fachkräftemangel ein wesentliches
Hemmnis für das weitere
Wirtschaftswachstum ist und damit den
Wohlstand auch in Deutschland gefährden
könnte dann ist es doch gut und vor
allen Dingen richtig Deutschland für
ausländische Fachkräfte attraktiver zu
machen und hier haben wir bereits ein
Mosaikbild vorge Monat einzelne
Mosaiksteine haben wir bereits
eingesetzt das chancenaufenthaltsrecht
kommt wir werden mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz mit dem
Familiennachzug und mit dem
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht weitere
Mosaiksteine in dieses Bild reinsetzen
und ich sage auch allen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hier im Haus ein Mosaikbild
muss durch schnelle Vervollständigung
der kleinen Steine die da rein gehören
durch die vielen kleinen Diskussionen in
den einzelnen Gesetzen aber am Ende des
Tages zu einem stimmigen Gesamtbild
führen und dieses Gesamtbild werden wir
als ampelregierung auch sehr schnell
zeichnen und bilden
der schnelle und vor allem schnellere
Erwerb der deutschen Staatsangehörigkeit
und damit eine sichere Perspektive in
Deutschland kann ein weiterer wichtiger
Baustein sein um Fachkräfte zu
motivieren nach Deutschland zu kommen
beziehungsweise dauerhaft auch hier zu
bleiben eine Debatte oder
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht das von
Restaurants und Stimmungsmacher
allerdings geprägt ist wird eine
modernen Einwanderungsland nicht gerecht
und entspricht und entspricht auch nicht
der Meinung der politischen und
gesellschaftlichen Mehrheit die Reform
unsere staatsangehörigkeitsrechtes ist
eine große Chance unseren
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt zu
stärken und ich glaube um es mal etwas
poetisch vielleicht zu sagen nichts ist
stärker als eine Idee deren Zeit
gekommen ist mittlerweile gibt es auch
die entsprechenden Mehrheiten im
Deutschen Bundestag dazu so abgewandelt
mit Viktor go danke ich Ihnen für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit danke
Mahmut Özdemir als parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär bei der Bundesministerin
des Innern und für Heimat hat ja an
Sachlichkeit appelliert in dieser
Debatte sich dann die eine und andere
Polemik Richtung Unionsfraktion doch
nicht ganz verkneifen können Irene Mia
Litsch ist sambold erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht bekommt ein
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht das Menschen
eine bessere eine verbindlichere
Integrationsperspektive eröffnet die
demokratischen Erfordernissen rechnen
und trägt und auch gut für unsere
Wirtschaft ist wir haben ein
strukturellen Fachkräftemangel der
unseren Wohlstand und die
wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit
bedroht und all das müssen wir dringend
angehen meine Damen und Herren
die Welt verändert sich aber die
märzunion und das konnten wir in den
Beiträgen gerade eindrucksvoll wieder
hören irrlich dort irgendwo zwischen
Identitätspolitik Vorurteilen und
zündelnden narrativen hin und her und
damit schaden sie aber dem
image-deutschlands ganz massiv meine
Damen und Herren
da wird der deutsche Pass als Ramschware
bezeichnet vor einem Black Friday wird
gewarnt und sie lieber Thorsten frei sie
haben es jetzt gerade in ihrer Rede
nicht gesagt aber in ihrem Interview im
ZDF da durfte man ihn dabei zuhören wie
sie davon gesprochen haben die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft dürfen nicht ich
zitiere ohne weitere Leistung verliehen
werden nun Herr frei was war eigentlich
genau ihre Leistung die sie zum
deutschen Staatsbürger befähigt hat das
mag sich für sie absurd anhören das mag
sich für sie vollständig absurd anhören
aber die gleiche Frage die gleiche Frage
stellen sie ja in diesem Debatten
Menschen die genauso wie sie hier
geboren und aufgewachsen sind und nein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie
merken es ja vielleicht selber bei
Staatsbürgerschaft geht es eben nicht um
Leistung es geht um bestimmte
Voraussetzungen ja das ist richtig und
die hat Mahmut Özdemir gerade
eindrucksvoll dargestellt wohin da die
Reise gehen soll aber vor allem geht es
um die Möglichkeit gleichberechtigt zum
Erfolg unseres Gemeinwesens beizutragen
und in diesem Geist werden wir das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht novellieren
wir führen diese Debatten wer dazu
gehört und wer nicht ja schon seit
Jahrzehnten und es ist ehrlich gesagt
unerträglich dass Menschen die keinen
deutschen Pass haben sich hier ständig
beweisen und erklären müssen oder dass
Menschen mit zwei Staatsangehörigkeiten
die Loyalität zu unserem Land hier
abgesprochen wird und auch die Union war
in ihrer Integrationspolitik schon
einmal weiter und auch sie haben etliche
Leute in ihren eigenen Reihen die
eingebürgert wurden erstens fragt man
sich wo die heute eigentlich alle sind
wahrscheinlich ist es ertragen sie es
nicht Ihnen hier zuzuhören und jetzt
führen Sie die Debatte ja im Stil der
90er Jahre wie bei Koch und Kanter ja
wie erklären sie das eigentlich ihren
eigenen Leuten und
daran merkt man einfach dass sie nach 16
Jahren Angela Merkel einfach noch gar
keine haben wo gar keine Ahnung haben wo
in ihre Reise eigentlich gehen soll das
ist natürlich sehr bequem für Sie mit
einer ordentlichen Portion Populismus
ihre eigene Orientierungslosigkeit
irgendwie zu überdenken aber genau
deshalb bin ich eigentlich sehr gespannt
was sie morgen bei der Abstimmung machen
werden wenn es um das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht geht da können sie ja
mal zeigen ob sie auf die Wirtschaft
hören und den dauerhaften Aufenthalt von
dringend gebrauchten Fachkräften
ermöglichen wollen oder ob Sie lieber
oder ob Sie lieber so wie jetzt hier in
die Debatte rechts abbiegen nein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir reden hier
dauernd über amtliche Dokumente aber
dabei geht es um Menschen meine Damen
und Herren
es sind Menschen mit ihren persönlichen
Biografien mit ihren Familien mit ihren
individuellen Plänen ihr Leben zu
gestalten und Herr Merz hat gestern
Morgenmagazin gesagt dass die die wir
hier haben wollen leider nicht kommen
tja da kann man sich ja mal fragen woran
das eigentlich liegt Herr frei hat sich
ja eben auch darüber beklagt dass die
Debatte hier keinen guten Ton hat ja das
teile ich ausdrücklich ja wenn wenn
diese Menschen sehen wenn diese Menschen
mitbekommen wie hier die Debatte geführt
wird und Worte wir haben schware hören
dann ist das ein Schlag ins Gesicht dann
fühlt man sich hier schlicht und
ergreifend unerwünscht und ich mache das
jetzt mal ganz persönlich auch ich wurde
eingebürgert als junger Mensch am
dritten oktober im Jahr 1983 als Kind
von Eltern aus dem ehemaligen
Jugoslawien die in den 60er Jahren nach
Deutschland gekommen sind und hier Leben
lang gearbeitet haben und wenn mein
Vater der als rohrschlösser angestellt
war am Abend in die Kneipe gehen wollte
da war er sehr vertraut damit wenn es
hieß Gastarbeiter sind hier unerwünscht
und genau genommen war er noch nicht
einmal Gastarbeiter sondern hatte einen
ganz anderes Anstellungsverhältnis aber
das spielt hier gar keine Rolle denn es
geht um das was dahinter steckt wenn ich
heute an seine Erzählungen zurückdenke
ja dann versetzt mir das immer noch ein
Stich ins Herz denn es muss endlich
Schluss sein damit Begriffe zu verwenden
die auf verletzende Weise andere
Menschen diskriminieren nur weil sie
eben nicht seit Generationen hier in
Deutschland leben ja und da sie von der
Union immer so gerne über Leistung
sprechen ja ich wünsche mir dass sie
explizit mal die Lebensleistung gerade
der älteren Generation würdigen die
wesentlich dazu beigetragen hat unser
Land nach der dunkelsten Zeit unserer
Geschichte wieder aufzubauen diese
Denkweise sollten wir endlich hinter uns
lassen meine Damen und Herren mit einem
neuen Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
Deutschland ist ein Einwanderungsland
und es wird Zeit dass das Recht dieser
Tatsache endlich rechn beträgt ganz
herzlichen Dank
Irene mich aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen mit Anmerkungen am Ende zu
ihrer Familiengeschichte einer
Zuwanderungsgeschichte auch die
rednerinnen-liste in dieser Debatte
insgesamt gibt eigentlich auch schon ein
ganz schönen Querschnitt über die
Zuwanderungsgeschichte die jüngere
Zuwanderungsgeschichte der
Bundesrepublik Stefan thomey ist der
nächste Redner parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer in der FDP-Fraktion
sind Teil eines
Gesamtkonzeptes eines Gesamtkunstwerkes
morgen wird der Deutsche Bundestag hier
ein Gesetz beschließen zu Beschleunigung
der Asyl und asylgerichtsverfahren weil
wir der Meinung sind dass diese zu lange
dauern sie dauern im Bundesschnitt
zurzeit über 26 Monate das ist zu lange
das wollen wir beschleunigen meine Damen
und Herren wir werden morgen ebenfalls
viel Bundestag ein Gesetz beschließen
zum Chancen Aufenthalt weil wir Probleme
aus der Vergangenheit lösen wollen dass
viele Menschen vier jahrelang geduldet
sind und wegen dieser diesen diese
duldungsstatus
über lange Zeit im Sozialsystem kleben
bleiben nicht richtig vorankommen können
nicht integriert werden in unserer
arbeitsmarktsystem und damit entgehen
diesem Land viele viele viel zu viele
Chancen und das wollen wir ändern meine
Damen und Herren
das wird morgen geschehen und gestern
hat das Bundeskabinett Eckpunkte zu
einem Gesetz zur Arbeitskräfte
Einwanderung mit einem Punktesystem
beschlossen wie es Kanada Australien
Neuseeland kennen wir wollen das
zukünftig Einwanderung gezielt und
kontrolliert stattfinden kann und auch
das ist ein Teil unseres Konzeptes
ein weiteres Projekt wird sein dass wir
Arbeitskräfte und deren Familien besser
bei uns integrieren auch das ist Teil
eines Gesamtkonzeptes meine Damen und
Herren und natürlich auch das ist ein
Teil der Wahrheit
können nicht alle kommen und es können
halt eben auch nicht alle bleiben
Integrationsförderung ist das eine was
wir wollen und was wir brauchen die
Versionskontrolle ist natürlich auch das
andere muss sich da ehrlich machen nicht
alle die Asyl bei uns beantragen haben
ein validen Asylgrund und nicht alle die
gerne bei uns arbeiten würden bringen
dafür die Voraussetzungen mit deswegen
brauchen wir auch Migrationskontrolle
und deswegen brauchen wir auch eine
konsequentere Rückführung aber
aber wenn eine individuelle persönliche
Einwanderungsgeschichte gelingt wenn
jemand sich wirtschaftlich rechtlich
sprachlich kulturell gut bei uns
integriert und Teil unserer Gesellschaft
auf Dauer werden will dann ist es doch
eine positive eine gute Botschaft meine
Damen und Herren am Ende eines solchen
Weges und deswegen geht es nicht darum
deutsche Pässe zu verrauschen sondern es
geht darum Anreize zu setzen sich bei
uns zu integrieren Teil unserer
Gesellschaft und Landes werden zu wollen
und dafür geben wir ein
aufstiegsversprechen für alle die es
doch eine Leistung in diesem Land zu
etwas bringen wollen und wir zeigen auch
wir moderieren das wir wertschätzen das
wir würdigen das indem wir schneller
eine andere Chance dafür gewähren das
ist unser Gesamtplan meine Damen und
Herren je mehr jemand beiträgt desto
schneller kann er auch bei uns ein
gewürfelt werden
und wir wollen auch eine großzügigere
mehrstaatlichkeitsregelung denn es kann
doch gute Gründe geben weshalb jemand
nicht die alte Staatsbürgerschaft gleich
ablegen kann oder will weshalb wir nicht
alle Bande zu alten Heimat durchtrennen
möchte weil ein Teil der Familie schon
hier lebt ein anderer Teil aber noch in
der alten Heimat lebt oder weil es
erbrechtliche oder andere Nachteile bei
der Ausbürgerung geben kann was wir aber
auch wollen ist dass wir uns nochmal
genau anschauen welche Konsequenzen es
haben kann wenn sich eine
Mehrstaatlichkeit über Generationen
immer weiter und weiter vererbt oder
nicht ein Generation Schnitt irgendwann
auch angebracht ist deswegen machen wir
ein echtes einbürgerungsangebot für alle
die bei uns bleiben und leben wollen wir
verlangen aber auch eine gewisse
investitionsleistung das ist ein Geben
und Nehmen und das halte ich für
angemessen und angebracht und das sind
die Pläne der Bundesregierung zur
Einwirkung meine Damen und Herren
Stefan thorme aus der FDP-Fraktion wo er
parlamentarisch Geschäftsführer ist der
nächste Redner in dieser Debatte Stefan
Heck sein aus der Unionsfraktion es
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Inneres und
Heimat
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir sprechen heute in
dieser aktuellen Stunde erneut über ein
wichtiges Thema Migrationspolitik ein
Politik fällt das nicht nur hier im
Deutschen Bundestag uns regelmäßig
beschäftigt sondern auch viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
und die Entscheidungen die wir hier als
Parlament treffen die unterscheiden sich
in einem ganz wesentlichen Punkt von
vielen anderen Beschlüssen die wir hier
fassen Fehlentscheidungen in diesem
Bereich können meist nicht mehr
rückgängig gemacht werden und wenn
rechtssetzungen und Verwaltungshandeln
in diesem Bereich Erfolg haben sollen
dann müssen sie von drei Elementen
geprägt sein erstens eine notwendigen
Maß an Offenheit zweitens der Fähigkeit
zur tiefgründigen Differenzierung also
unterschiedliche Sachverhalte auch
unterschiedlich zu behandeln und
drittens der erforderlichen Konsequenz
und auch Härte bei der Durchsetzung
rechtsstaatlich getroffener Entscheidung
und
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die
Bilanz ihrer Regierung nach knapp einem
Jahr im Amt in diesem Gesamtthema
Migrationspolitik ist verheerend die von
ihnen angekündigt und eben noch mal
angesprochene europäische Initiative zur
flüchtlingsverteilung ist schon nach
wenigen Wochen komplett gescheitert der
Zustrom an Schutz suchen ist heute so
groß wie nie zuvor und sie lassen
Bürgermeister und Landräte im Regen
stehen stattdessen wollen Sie
stattdessen wollen sie morgen im
Deutschen Bundestag ein Gesetz
beschließen dass nun auch denjenigen
Ausländern ein Aufenthaltsrecht zukommen
lässt die ihre Identität bewusst
verschleiern von der versprochenen
abschiebe Initiative wir haben es ja
heute wieder gehört ist bislang nichts
übrig geblieben die Stelle des
abschiebeauftragten die FDP meint es
immer wieder an ist immer noch unbesetzt
noch immer sind rund 300.000
ausreisepflichtigen in unserem Land
darunter auch Gefährder und Straftäter
als wäre das nicht genug wollen sie nun
auch noch die Axt an unser bewährtes
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht legen danach
soll der Doppelpass nicht die Ausnahme
bleiben sondern zu regeln werden wir
sind fest überzeugt das ist ein fataler
Irrweg und es ist sozialer Sprengstoff
für unser Land
[Applaus]
für uns als Union ist klar wer sich hier
gut integriert hat wenn die deutsche
Sprache erlernt hat und die notige
Wartezeit erfüllt hat der kann die
deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit beantragen
und dabei sollte es auch weiterhin
bleiben wir freuen uns über jeden der
sich zu unserem Land bekennt und das mit
einer Einbürgerung auch besiegeln will
für uns aber auch klar meine Damen und
Herren der deutsche Pass ist mehr als
ein Stück Papier er steht am Ende und
nicht am Anfang der Integration
staatsbürgerliche
staatsbürgerliche Loyalität kann man
nicht einfach aufteilen zwischen zwei
Ländern in guten Zeiten Marktes kein
Problem sein in schweren Zeiten kann es
aber zu einer ganz erheblichen Belastung
für unsere Gesellschaft werden wir haben
eben über den Konflikt im Bereich des
Wehrdienstes schon gesprochen aber
soweit müssen wir ja gar nicht gehen
denken wir zurück an die groß angelegten
türkischen Demonstrationen zu
Unterstützung des türkischen Präsidenten
Erdogan in Köln und anderen deutsche
Städten da waren Menschen auf den
Straßen die sprichwörtlich mit der einen
Hand ihren deutschen Pass hochgehalten
haben sich auf die Versammlungsfreiheit
ein Grundrecht das erst einmal nur für
deutsche Geld zu berufen und mit der
anderen Hand türkische Fahnen geschwenkt
haben und für einen Regime geworben
haben von Erdogan dass all diese Rechte
die wir hier haben ignoriert und mit
Füßen tritt es verwundert und ist
verwundert deshalb nicht dass die ganz
überragende Mehrheit der Deutschen diese
doppelpasspläne ablehnen aber es macht
auch deutlich ihre Pläne zum Doppelpass
sind falsch gefährlich und Sie müssen
dringend gestoppt werden
darüber hinaus hat die Bundesregierung
die forderte Aufenthaltsdauer in
Deutschland bis zur Einbürgerung vor
drastisch zu verkürzen wir sehen nicht
warum es einer solchen Änderung Bedarf
Handlungsbedarf gibt es gleichwohl und
zwar nicht in der Gesetzgebung sondern
im Verwaltungshandeln vor Ort und
deshalb wäre es gut gewesen Herr
nuripuri sprich sie mal an als
Frankfurter Abgeordneten es wäre gut
gewesen wenn sie als Verantwortliche der
Ampelkoalition vor diesen vollmundigen
Ankündigungen die wir hören mit ihren
kommunalen Vertretern vor Ort gesprochen
hätten in Frankfurt der größten Stadt
meines heimatbundeslandes Hessen der
fünf größten Stadt in Deutschland
regieren seit September SPD Grüne und
FDP gestern war der Frankfurter Neuen
Presse zu lesen dass in der dortigen
Ausländerbehörde seit etlichen Monaten
sage und schreibe 15.000 schriftliche
Anfragen einfach unbeantwortet geblieben
sind seit Monaten teilweise seit Jahren
warten mehrere tausend tüchtige Menschen
darauf dass die Verlängerung ihres visas
oder ihres Visums oder ihre
Arbeitserlaubnis
vorgenommen wird eine große Deutsche
Bank hat letzte Woche einen hochrangigen
Mitarbeiter freistellen müssen da trotz
zahlreicher Nachfragen keine
Entscheidung der Frankfurter
Ausländerbehörde erfolgte daraufhin hat
die Bank Dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde gegen
die gesamte Ausländerbehörde eingelegt
ein bis dahin wohl einmaliger Vorgang
das sind Vorgänge die in ihrer
Verantwortung in Frankfurt Ampel
stattfinden meine Damen und Herren
und ich frage mich schon ich frage mich
schon was muss in diesen vielen tausend
Menschen vorgehen die in Frankfurt
darauf warten dass sie endlich einen
Termin bei ihrer Ausländerbehörde
bekommen seit Monaten teilweise seit
Jahren darauf warten und jetzt der
nuripur von ihnen von Ihnen hier hören
müssen dass sie die Wartezeit gesetzlich
verkürzen wollen das muss doch wie
blanker hohen klingen für diese Menschen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich
komme zum Schluss wir kennen bislang nur
die Eckpunkte dieses Gesetzes aber die
genügend schon zu erkennen das ist
Kollegen völlig falsche Richtung geht
die Pläne sind spalterisch gefährlich
für unseren gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhang sie sollten da liegen sie
statt nehmen noch ist es nicht zu Ehren
zum Schluss gekommen Stefan Heck war das
er war von 19 bis 21 Staatssekretär im
hessischen Innenministerium und wir
gucken mal als
Verweis auf den übernächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt auf die
Regierungsbank der sitzt nämlich
Franziska Brandner Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin eben Ministerium beim
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ziemlich
eingemummelt und das mummelt und das
geht mir die Gelegenheit die noch mal zu
sagen dass sie Temperatur hier im
Plenarsaal des Deutschen Bundestags auch
nicht mehr über 19 Grad geheizt wird
also da muss man sich schon mal ganz gut
einpacken und dann ist es auch wenn man
länger da sitzt etwas frisch und
Franziska Brandner wird noch etwas
länger da sitzen müssen wir sind zurück
in der Aktuellen Stunde zum Thema
Einbürgerung und Migration und es
spricht Herr kann dem hier aus der
SPD-Fraktion
und uns selber sagen können wir haben in
den letzten vier Jahren
diese Gesellschaft weiter stärker
zusammengerückt
und ich frage mich ob das nach dieser
Debatte die ich jetzt heute gehört habe
spätestens nach dieser Debatte die
cdu/csu überhaupt so noch sagen kann
und noch eine Sache und die stelle ich
mir wirklich
sie haben ja unter ihnen ja auch
Politikerinnen und Politiker mit
doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft
Politikerinnen und Politiker die
eingebürgert worden sind sie haben
wahrscheinlich auch Menschen die
eingebürgert worden sind und Sie gewählt
haben aber auch da spätestens nach
dieser Debatte
müsste man sich doch die Frage stellen
kann man diese Partei noch wählen oder
müsste man nicht aus dieser Partei sogar
austreten nach all dem was sie heute
gesagt haben
und die Differenzierung ja wir sind für
Differenzierung also sie haben aber hier
noch nichts differenziert sie könnten ja
sagen wir möchten nicht nach fünf Jahren
sondern sie könnten sagen wie in San
Marino noch 25 Jahre aber das bringen
sie ja nicht rein sondern sie führen die
gleichen debatten wie vor 20 Jahren und
das ist offenbar das Verständnis von
konservativ sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
gut dass wir heute über die
Staatsangehörigkeit das über das
Staatsangehörigkeitsgesetz sprechen und
es wurde schon heute häufiger genannt
deshalb verstehe ich auch den Punkt mit
der
den Punkt nicht zu sagen wir vertrauen
den Menschen vielleicht bisschen weniger
weil sie den doppelten Pass haben 69
Prozent wenn wir uns das letzte Jahr
angucken 69% der Menschen haben die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft und das
funktioniert gut es funktioniert gut und
diese Debatte die wir heute führen
führen wir bei diesem 69% nicht warum
sollten wir es bei den restlichen 31%
führen liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
[Applaus]
und heute geht es nicht nur darum dass
wir sagen
die voraufenthaltszeit geht von acht auf
fünf Jahre runter es geht auch nicht nur
um die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
sondern es geht darum wie können wir
auch die Demokratie im Land stärken
wollen wir das Menschen früher
mitbestimmen können gewählt werden
können selber wählen oder wollen wir
dass es später funktioniert und ich
glaube als Demokratin und Demokraten
muss es doch klar sein wenn wir die
Chance haben dass Menschen früher
mitbestimmen dürfen und können dann
sollten wir auch das Nutzen liebe
Freunde
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
1999 ist meine Familie mit mir zusammen
gewechselt wir haben die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft angenommen und einige
Jahre später konnten meine Eltern zum
ersten Mal wählen und ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern wie glücklich sie waren
und und ich kann mich noch daran
erinnern dass auch meine Mutter am
Infostand tatsächlich auch der SPD eine
Rose bekommen hat und sich gesehen und
anerkannt gefühlt hat und das kann
natürlich ein Dorn in ihrem in ihren
Augen sein zu sagen da sind jetzt
Menschen die vielleicht andere Parteien
wählen als sie jetzt möchten aber das
gehört auch zu deren Recht wir gehen mit
dieser neuen Reform diesen Weg weiter
und ich hoffe
dass wir nach der Legislatur alle hier
in den Spiegel schauen können und sagen
können wir haben es gemeinsam geschafft
dass dieses Land nach diesen vier Jahren
näher zusammengerückt ist das ist unser
Ziel auf jeden Fall und ich würde mich
freuen wenn Sie dieses Ziel auch haben
danke schön
Matthias Helferich hat das Wort
und Matthias Helferich war mal in der
afd-fraktion jetzt ist er fraktionslos
das Kanzler Scholz hat Recht wenn er
feststellt ich zitiere eine Demokratie
lebt von der Möglichkeit mit zu
bestimmen so entsteht Legitimität so
wächst die Akzeptanz staatliche
Entscheidung es ist
demokratietheoretisch ein Unding das
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland leben
die nicht demokratisch partizipieren
können die gebotene Antwort ist es aber
nun gerade nicht diese Menschen mit der
deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft
auszustatten sondern Deutschland endlich
vor dem Austausch seines Souveräns zu
schützen es bedeutet den Abschied von
uns selbst wenn sie die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zum reinen
Berechtigungsschein diskreditieren wie
ist der Staatsrechtler Peter Graf
klimansek erklärte die Demokratie
benötigt wie ernst denke klar stellte
die gemeinsame Sprache kulturbewusstsein
Tradition Abstammung gleiche
verfassungsvorstellungen als
gedeihensvoraussetzung ihr Angriff auf
unserer Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht die
Herabwürdigung unseres Volkes auf ein
Nebeneinander von Parallelgesellschaften
die Regierung des Volkes als
Schicksalsgemeinschaft wird ein Quest
von Historikern als demokratiefeindlich
bewertet werden und es ist ja zu
begrüßen wenn Migranten in der deutschen
Kultur aufgehen aber seien wir doch mal
ehrlich wer will es den Millionen
türkischen doppelpassinhabern eigentlich
verübeln sich weiter als Türken in
unserem Land zu führen das Volk als
organische Einheit braucht
identitätsstiftenwerte und auch ein
Mythos pubertätsblocker für Kinder
Regenbogenfahnen gratismut und morbide
selbstauflösungsromantik sind eben nicht
attraktiv die Aufweichung unsere
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht die Auflösung
unserer Identität als Land der Deutschen
sind ja im Kontext ihrer Agenda
konsequent das ist ja alles konsequent
und folgt einem großen Plan für jene die
aber trotzdem unsere Verfassung stehen
ist das ebenso konsequent gegen ihre
ersetzungsligation den großen Austausch
des Souveränität aufzubegehren der
zentrale Begriff der Demokratie ist eben
das Volk und sich die Menschheit folgen
Sie lieber Karl Schmidt und stimmen Sie
gegen jede weitere Liberalisierung des
Staatsbürgerschaftsrechts vielen Dank
[Applaus]
christian jüksel hat jetzt das Wort für
die SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren auf den Tribünen
können Sie sich vorstellen bei der
Abstimmung zum neuen
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht nicht mit
Stimmen zu dürfen ich weiß wie sich das
anfühlt denn ich war viele Jahre von
demokratischen Wahlen ausgeschlossen als
ich das erste Mal in meinem Leben wählen
durfte war schon Mitte 30 zu diesem
Zeitpunkt habe ich bereits 28 Jahre in
Deutschland gelebt hier gearbeitet und
mich auch ehrenamtlich engagiert
Deutschland war längst zu meiner Heimat
geworden aber ohne die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit gehört die ich
rechtlich nicht dazu
können Sie auf der rechten Seite zuhören
vielleicht können Sie auch noch mal was
dazu lernen ja dann gehen sie raus das
ist vielleicht viel besser
das zeigte sich auch im Alltag die
Wohnungsuche scheiterte immer wieder ich
hatte sogar
ich darf alles sagen was ich möchte weil
ich bin deutsche Staatsbürgerin genauso
wie viele andere also hatten sie einfach
mal den Mund
also das zeigte sich auch im Alltag denn
die Wohnung suche scheiterte immer
wieder ich hatte sogar Probleme eine
Kfz-Versicherung zu finden nicht einmal
an Bürger entscheiden dürfte ich
teilnehmen es war daher ein sehr
emotionaler Moment ein unbeschreibliches
Gefühl dann das erste Mal meinen
deutschen Pass in den Händen zu halten
das erste Mal zu wählen und mit den
entscheiden zu dürfen das Gefühl Teil
dieses Landes zu sein es wird daher Zeit
dass wir die Rahmenbedingungen endlich
an die Lebenswirklichkeiten anpassen
wir als Ampelkoalition packen das mit
dem neuen Staatsangehörigkeitsgesetz an
wir erleichtern den Weg zur deutschen
Staatsbürgerschaft gerade auch für die
Menschen die schon längst
selbstverständlich Teil dieser
Gesellschaft sind dazu verhelfen wir
nicht nur zu einer schnelleren
Einbürgerung und damit zu schneller und
Integration wir ermöglichen auch die
Mehrstaatlichkeit für bestimmte
Herkunftsländer ist das übrigens heute
schon in Deutschland Normalfall aber
eben nicht für alle so kann aktuell ein
EU-Bürger eine EU-Bürgerin oder ein
Bürger aus der Schweiz seinen Pass
behalten
wären zum Beispiel eine Bürgerin oder
ein Bürger aus der Türkei ihn abgeben
muss nach unserer Reform wird die
Mehrstaatlichkeit außerdem für deutsche
gelten die nach Erwerb einer weiteren
Staatsangehörigkeit im Ausland ihren
Pass nicht mehr verlieren werden eine
Einbürgerung im EU-Ausland dürfen
deutlich Deutschland dürfen deutsche
übrigens schon jetzt ihren Pass behalten
viele dieser deutschen ausgewanderten
werden sicher verstehen dass ein Pass
eben nicht nur ein Stück Papier ist
sondern mit einem Gefühl und einer
Identität verbunden ist
das neue Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht wird
auch die Hürden für die einbung der
Gastarbeitergeneration senken denn die
Gastarbeiterinnen und Gastarbeiter haben
Deutschland zum Wohlstand verholfen ihre
Lebensleistung wollen wir hiermit
wertschätzen und anerkennen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der
Union entgegen ihrer Darstellung und
bleiben die zentralen
einbürgerungskriterien natürlich
weiterhin erhalten wie etwa der
Sprachnachweis oder die Sicherung des
Lebensunterhaltes wenn sie jetzt in der
CDU und CSU trotzdem davon sprechen dass
die Staatsangehörigkeit verrampt oder
entwertet würde dann ist das wirklich
verletzend ist ihre deutsche
staatsangeht ist ihre deutsche Identität
weniger wert seitdem auch ich den
deutschen Pass besitze oder wird ihr
passt zusammenschware wenn ich Ihnen
sage dass ich eine doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft habe mit ihrer
Wortwahl legen Sie genau das nahe und
das ist einfach unerträglich
wie wichtig ist übrigens diese Debatte
ist zeigt auch ein Blick in ihren Reihen
sie haben die Aktuelle Stunde
Beantragung schauen Sie mal wie viele
von ihren Kollegen Kollegen dort sitzen
liebe Kollegen Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren der deutsche
Pass ist wertvoll wer könnte das besser
wissen als die Menschen die ihn nicht
per Geburt sondern ihn per Einbürgerung
erhalten haben aber nicht nur der
deutsche Pass ist wertvoll auch die
Menschen die sich um den Pass bemühen
wertvoll für unser Land sind zum
Beispiel die Türkei stämmigen
bayern-gründerichi
wertvoll für dieses Land war mein Vater
der mit so vielen Gastarbeitern und
Gastarbeitern das Wirtschaftswunder in
diesem Land erst möglich machte und
wertvoll sind die Migrantinnen und
Migranten die auch heute zusammen mit
ihren deutschen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
den Laden am Laufen halten auf an der
Supermarktkasse
als Lehrkraft oder am Krankenbett liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir können froh sein wenn sich möglichst
viele von ihnen für die Einbürgerung
entscheiden und aktiv das
gesellschaftliche Zusammenleben in
unserem Land Deutschland mitgestalten
können herzlichen Dank
güdesheim der SPD-Fraktion war die
vorletzte Rednerin in dieser aktuellen
Stunde die auf Antrag der Unionsfraktion
stattfindet und in der es um die Pläne
der Koalition der Bundesregierung zu
einer schnelleren Einbürgerung geht
letzter Redner aus der SPD-Fraktion
einer der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
Dirk Wiese
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen am Schluss der
Debatte gibt es einem noch mal die gute
Möglichkeit etwas zusammen zu fassen und
ich glaube wir haben heute zwei klare
Alternativen hier gesehen wir haben eine
Ampelkoalition die Fortschritt für
dieses Land will die dieses Land
voranbringen will die gerade im Bereich
der Einwanderungspolitik die Fenster
aufmachen will frischen Wind reinbringen
will die Lebensrealitäten anerkannen
will und wir haben eine cdu/csu-fraktion
die mit Friedrich Merz zurück in die
50er Jahre wird das ist die klare
Alternative die sich hier heute in
dieser Debatte gezeigt hat
und ich muss das schon sagen wenn ich
dir diese Debatte mir noch mal vom
Beginn des letzten Wochenendes bis jetzt
vor Augen führe die Union hat gemerkt
dass sie möglicherweise ein Thema
erkannt hat sie wollte polemisieren sie
wollte dieses Thema nutzen vielleicht
zum parteipolitischen Vorteil was
passiert denn dann diese Woche innerhalb
der Union wird diskutiert 26 oder 24
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union sagen
beim Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht naja das
was die Ampel davor schließt ist doch
mal Sonne gar nicht so eine schlechte
Idee und wir machen mal ein offenes
einen Brief und sagen das ist gut
zustimmen wollen wir noch nicht aber
enthalten und das ist ja auch schon mal
ein Zeichen an sich das ist der eine
Punkt dann redet Stefan Heck gerade hier
am Pult und hält eine Rede lieber
Kollege Heck die ich vorsichtig
formuliere etwas für fragwürdig halte in
dem Moment wo sie hier diese Rede halten
äußert sich der hessische
Ministerpräsident auf dem Ticker der
hessische Ministerpräsident kritisiert
die eigene Partei für beleidigende und
verunglimpfende Rhetorik und ruft seine
eigene Partei zur Mäßigung auch Stefan
Heck nichts davon mitbekommen am sage
dann sehen wir die Debatte so die Union
ruft dann diese aktuelle Stunde auf und
möchte natürlich mit dieser aktuellen
Stunde natürlich auch die Ampelkoalition
etwas vorführen das gibt es manchmal im
politischen Berlin ist aber um es
nochmal vorsichtig auszudrücken etwas
schief gegangen Friedrich Merz
Erkenntnis selber und hat ungefähr vor
einer halben Stunde die Debatte
verlassen das ist die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion im 21
Jahrhundert und jetzt will ich mal ein
paar Punkte ansprechen ich meine das
muss man sich mal vor Augen führen da
wird jahrelang darüber geredet dass es
innerhalb der cdu/csu einen anderen Pack
gibt diesen andenpackt ich habe gesehen
dass da viele ältere Herrschaften der
Union drin sind ich habe gedacht den
gibt's gar nicht mehr diese Woche kommt
der anpackt wieder zum Leben und wenn
ihr sie die Woche richtig gut
abschließen wollen aber nennen sie
wahrscheinlich am Ende der Woche noch
Roland Koch zum migrationsbeauftragten
der cdu-bundestation
und jetzt will ich mal auf die Punkte
eingehen worüber wir reden wir reden
über migrationspolitische Vorhaben der
Ampel die Lebensrealitäten in diesem
Land anerkennen und ich sage das auch
mal ganz deutlich da sind wir weiter als
sie und übrigens auch hier in deutschen
Bundestag es gibt so viele tolle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier in den
Fraktionen die die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft haben die bereichernd
sind für dieses Land und das gibt es
auch draußen in den Wahlkreisen und wir
brauchen doch auch gerade Fachkräfte wir
brauchen Arbeitskräfte wir brauchen
Zuwanderung das ist doch das was uns die
Wirtschaftsunternehmen immer wieder
sagen aber ihre Rhetorik die sie über
Jahre geführt haben die hat mit dazu
geführt dass Fachkräfte um die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland einen Bogen
machen wir sind unattraktiv für
Fachkräfte und ich sage Ihnen mal auf
woran das liegt das liegt an einem
Jürgen Rückers Kinder statt Kinder das
sind Formulierungen die sind bei Ihnen
wieder aktuell auf der Tagesordnung gar
nicht zu sprechen es ist angesprochen
worden von der Kampagne gegen die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft in Hessen
und nicht würde es nicht überraschen mit
irgendein jetzt aus ihren Reihen auch
hier wieder auf die Idee kommen das
voranzubringen und ich sage das mal ganz
deutlich das was wir vorhaben dass wir
eine Fachkräfte einwanderungsstrategie
gestern vorgelegt haben das ist gut und
richtig und wir brauchen das auch da
muss fachkräftezuwanderung geregelt
werden und das was wir bisher haben
reicht jedenfalls nicht aus um die
Fachkräfte und Arbeitskräfte Lücke bei
uns im Land zu schließen das werden wir
auf den Weg bringen und genauso gut
werden wir morgen das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht auf den Weg bringen es
kann doch nicht sein dass Menschen die
jahrelang bei uns sind die hier in einem
duldungsstatus sind die oftmals auch
abgeschoben werden direkt von Ihrem
Arbeitsplatz die Kinder werden aus der
Schule geholt diesen Menschen müssen wir
doch eine Perspektive geben und dass wir
denen diese Perspektive morgen mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht ermöglichen das
ist richtig und das ist eine gute
Entscheidung auch diese Ampel-Koalition
und dann komme ich noch mal zur
Staatsbürgerschaft und ich bin auch froh
ich hatte da diese Woche Kollege Kohle
einmal so ein Interview und
Deutschlandfunk gehört die war ein
bisschen erstaunt weil der Werder redet
dann was der Kollege durch ich bin ja
froh dass wir heute die Kurve Geschichte
haben aber auch bei diesem
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht will ich doch
mal sagen die Anerkennung der doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft dass wir das möglich
machen dass wir auch die
Lebensleistungen der
Gastarbeitergeneration anerkennen die
dieses Land mit aufgebaut haben das ist
doch richtig und auch die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft ist doch auch schon
Alltag in vielen Ländern Europas ist
Alltag bei vielen Menschen hier bei uns
im Land die einen doppelten Pass haben
und darum werden wir das gemeinsam
voranbringen wir als Ampelkoalition
wollen Fortschritt in diesem Land das
werden wir schaffen das werden wir
umsetzen und das tut der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland im 21 Jahrhundert gut vielen
Dank
Dirk Wiese war der letzte Redner in der
Aktuellen Stunde des Bundestags zum
Thema schneller Einbürgerung morgen
steht das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht auf
der Agenda im Bundestag um 9 Uhr aber um
8:45 Uhr haben wir dazu schon zwei MdB
beide aus Berlin beide Generalsekretäre
ihrer Partei nämlich Kevin Kühnert und
Mario chaia im Interview das wollte ich
Ihnen jetzt schon mal ans Herz legen
außerdem will ich ihn an festlegen dass
wir auf eine Pressekonferenz warten
nämlich mit Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
und dem Nato-Generalsekretär Jens
Stoltenberg die ist für ca 16.30
angekündigt da gehen wir dann ganz fix
live drauf und sobald sie zu Ende ist
auch wieder zurück in den Bundestag der
nämlich diskutiert jetzt rufe
was Sanktionen oder die Durchsetzung von
Sanktionen gegen Russland bzw gegen
russische Oligarchen angeht man hat
jetzt in diesem
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz zwei unter
anderem vor eine neue Zentralstelle für
sanktionsdurchsetzung zu schaffen sie
soll im Geschäftsbereich des
Bundesfinanzministerium viele andere
Punkte spielen auch noch eine Rolle die
werden wir im Laufe der Debatte auch zu
hören bekommen Markus Herbrand ist
finanzpolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion und der erste Redner und
die Unterstützer von Putin ist ein
wichtiger Baustein im Kampf gegen die
eroberungsphantasien des russischen
Diktators
wir müssen Putins Freunde dort treffen
wo es ihnen wirklich auch wehtut bei
ihrem Kontostand bei ihren Willen und
ihren luxusspielzeugen von der Yacht bis
zum Rennpferd nur wenn die eigene Kuss
Kosten Nutzen Relation ins Negative gibt
werden sich immer mehr günstige mit
ihren Möglichkeiten für eine
Ära nach Wladimir Putin
Auseinandersetzen mit dem zweiten
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz
beschleunigen wir diese Überlegungen und
Stärken auch die
absatzbewegungen des russischen
Geldadels so schaffen wir mit der
Zentralstelle für sanktionsdurchsetzung
erstmals eine eigene Verwaltungseinheit
die sich mit der Analyse möglicher
sanktionsverstöße beschäftigt das
Aufspüren sanktionierter Vermögenswerte
in globalisierten Zeiten ist eben nicht
einfach mit einer Google-Suche
vergleichbar sondern bedarf schon den
Einsatz geschulter Spezialisten
denn viele Vermögenswerte sind in
komplexen Unternehmens und auch
rechtsstrukturen versteckt deren
Aufdeckung die Bündelung und Tiefe
Analyse vorhandener Daten erfordert mit
der Zentralstelle vereinen wir die dafür
notwendigen Werkzeuge erstmals unter
einem Dach von der von den
IT-Spezialisten über die Datenzugriffe
bis hin zur Verbesserung des vor sich
hindümpelten
transparenzregisters wird die
Zentralstelle alle Möglichkeiten nutzen
um die Sanktionen durchzusetzen dabei
ist gerade die Ertüchtigung des
transparenzregisters ein wichtiger
Meilenstein dessen Durchschlagskraft war
jahrelang begrenzt dass ich Unternehmer
hinter sogenannten mitteilungsfiktionen
verstecken konnten in der Folge waren
die oder der tatsächlich wirtschaftliche
berechtigte in vielen Fällen nicht
bekannt es ist gut dass die
Ampelkoalition dieses Versteckspiel
beendet und endlich Möglichkeiten
schafft um hinter die Kulissen zu
blicken die Union hat in Zeiten der
großen Koalition beharrlich gemauert und
der Geldwäschebekämpfung damit meines
Erachtens auch einen Bärendienst
erwiesen wir korrigieren nun diesen
Fehler zu Recht
zudem erhöhen wir durch die geplante
Verknüpfung dieses transparenzregisters
mit einer
immobilientransaktionsdatenbank die
Nachverfolgbarkeit finanzieller
Transaktionen weiter
konsequenter Weise gehört hierzu auch
das vereinbarte barzahlungsverbot bei
Immobilienkäufen das wirklich mehr als
überfällig war auch hier berechtigt die
ampelfehler an dieser Stelle kann und
will ich mir auch einen Satz zum Antrag
der Union nicht verkneifen den Zustand
den sie zu ändern beantragen den haben
nun wirklich sie selbst am meisten zu
verantworten sie waren es die unser Land
in den vergangenen 16 Jahren regiert
haben ihr Versuche sich dieser
Verantwortung zu entziehen sind sehr
beschaubar
wir werden nun rasch und konsequent die
Strukturen aufbauen wie wir zu
Erreichung dieser Ziele auch benötigen
ich danke auch dem Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner für seinen Engagement
in der Sache schon nach wenigen Monaten
in seiner Amtszeit hat sich bei der
strukturellen Bekämpfung der
Finanzkriminalität mehr getan als in
vielen Jahren zuvor eine weitere
Maßnahme
[Applaus]
zukünftig wird es auch möglich sein über
ein eigenes eingerichtetes Hinweis über
eine eigens eingerichtete Hinweis
Annahmestelle Verdachtsfälle zu
sanktionsverstößen direkt an kompetente
Ansprechpartner zu melden die mit unter
frustrierende Suche nach passenden
Ansprechpartnern im deutschen Behörden
Dschungel fällt damit weg aber wir
achten selbstverständlich auch darauf
dass das rechtsstaatlich und sauber
gemacht wird damit nicht neidgetriebene
Anzeigen gegen den beliebigen Nachbarn
oder die unsympathische Kollegin
überhaupt erst in den Kreislauf der
Ermittlungsbehörden geraten werden die
bei der Annahmestelle eingehenden
Meldungen selbstverständlich zunächst
auf ihre Werthaltigkeit überprüft und
dann erst in wenn ein Anfangsverdacht
besteht auf sanktionsverstöße dann erst
in die Tätigkeiten von Zentralstelle und
Ermittlungsbehörden überführt das ganze
das Ganze für das ganze Verfahren ist
wichtig wenn verdichte verdächtige
Personen ihre Mitwirkungen bei der Suche
nach mögen nach objektivieren
objektivierbaren Kriterien konsequent
verweigern dann sollen diese
mitwirkungsverweigerer ebenso konsequent
auch die Antwort des Rechtsstaates
erhalten und daran werden wir auch in
Zukunft weiter arbeiten
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
stellen mit dem vorliegenden Gesetz auch
die richtigen Weichen für die
erfolgreiche Geldwäsche Bekämpfung indem
die zentralstahl Zentralstelle als
eigene Verwaltungsbehörde aufgebaut wird
ist die spätere Eingliederung in das
geplante
bundesfinanzkriminalamt reibungslos
möglich kurz um wir sind auf dem absolut
richtigen Weg und daher kann es nur
Zustimmung vorliegenden Gesetz geben ich
bin am Ende meiner Ausführung und möchte
mich aber noch bei den Berichterstatter
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
koalitionsfraktion Gedanken herzlichen
Dank Kollege das ist natürlich immer
sehr erfreulich sich zu bedanken
trotzdem sind wir gerade bei halb drei
ich sage es nur für die letzten die dann
hier noch Dienste tun und die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
deswegen nehmen Sie mir das nicht
persönlich aber ich werde sehr strengen
darauf achten dass die Redezeiten
eingehalten werden Matthias Hauer hat
das Wort für die CDU CSU
und wir verweisen noch mal auf die
erweiterte Pressekonferenz von Jens
Stoltenberg und Bundeskanzler Scholz
sobald sie da ist wenn Sie die Live
bekommen aber jetzt wie angekündigt von
der Bundestags viel zu Präsidentin
Matthias Hauer
SPD Grüne und FDP mit ihrem Gesetz
leider und sie handeln gegen die
einhelligen Ratschläge der Fachleute als
Zitat unausgegoren untauglich halbherzig
und behäbig Zitat Ende bewertet es zum
Beispiel die Gewerkschaft der Polizei
das Gesetz ist ein Totalausfall mit
Ansage die Ampel blockiert
nutzungsverbote weiter lässt also die
sanktionierten Oligarchen die Kollege
Herbert gerade erwähnt hat weiter
unbehelligt in ihren Willen wohnen und
Luxusautos fahren keine Fortschritte
gibt es auch bei den Vermögen unklare
Herkunft bei der Transparenz im
Geschäftsverkehr begnügen sie sich
leider mit einer minimal-lösung
Herzstück des Gesetzes ist aber die neue
Zentralstelle für sanktions Durchsetzung
die soll erst einmal bei der General
Zolldirektion angesiedelt werden aber
auch das nur vorübergehend also eine
Übergangslösung nach der anderen die
ampelschaft einen zuständigkeitswirr war
und eine neue zahnlose Behörde ohne
klare Kompetenzen
wir als unionsfraktionen schlagen
stattdessen vor die Zuständigkeiten bei
einer zollpolizei zu bündeln und sie mit
angemessenen Befugnissen auszustatten
damit könnte Vermögen aufgespürt werden
sanktioniertes Vermögen verdächtiges
Vermögen und auch Vermögen unklarer
Herkunft das wäre ein großer Schritt bei
der sanktionsdurchsetzung und bei der
Geldwäschebekämpfung und das bestätigen
auch die Sachverständigen auf die
Sachverständigen will die Ampel aber
bekanntlich nicht hören als sie das
Gesetz geschrieben haben spielten die ja
auch keine Rolle Gewerkschaften
Berufsverbände die hatten damals 45
Stunden Zeit von der Ampel bekommen um
diesen knapp 100-seitigen Referenten
Entwurf zu bewerten damit haben sie die
Beteiligung zu einer Fass gemacht und
als die Sachverständigen dann endlich zu
Wort gekommen sind in der öffentlichen
Anhörung im Finanzausschuss da haben die
Sachverständigen kein gutes Haar an der
von der Ampel vorgesehenen Struktur
gelassen und ich habe zum Beispiel auch
der SPD-Kollege Fiedler zutreffend vor
wenigen Tagen bei einer öffentlichen
Veranstaltung bei transparents
international festgestellt komisch dass
ich heute den auf der Rednerliste gar
nicht finde da hätten mich die
Ausführung doch interessiert und dennoch
trotz dieser ganzen Ratschläge der
einheitlichen Sachverständigen ziehen
SPD Grüne und FDP diesen Totalausfall
weiter durch sie ignorieren den
fachlichen Rat der Profis und weil die
Ampel ihr Gesetz im Finanzausschuss über
den grünen Klee gelobt hat und mein
Folge Redner dr Zimmermann wird das
gleich auch tun da bin ich sicher möchte
ich mal die Sachverständigen in dieser
Debatte zu Wort kommen lassen und dafür
stelle ich Ihnen gerne die Hälfte meiner
Redezeit zur Verfügung die Gewerkschaft
der Polizei Bezirksgruppe Zoll hat in
der Anhörung gesagt Zitat die GdP rät
von diesem Konstrukt gänzlich ab
wenn diese Behörde kein Unterbau hat
dann hat sie vor Ort vollkommen zahnlos
die Aufgaben können allesamt in
bestehenden Strukturen wahrgenommen
werden
der Bund Deutscher Kriminalbeamter
äußerte sich in der Anhörung in genau
die gleiche Richtung Zitat unser
Vorschlag ist dass wir die bestehenden
Kompetenzen nutzen müssen der BDK sagte
dass wir uns nicht leisten können Zitat
noch Jahre dafür zu verwenden um eine
Behörde zu strukturieren und aufzubauen
und auch das netzwerksteuergerechtigkeit
hat sich der Kritik in der Anhörung
angeschlossen Zitat wir haben auch mit
der GdP und dem BDK relativ ähnliche
Vorstellungen wie das in die bestehenden
Strukturen einsortiert werden kann und
genau die gleiche kritik kam in der
Anhörung auch von der Wissenschaft der
Strafrechtler Professor Wegner sagte
Zitat das ist
zweckmäßiger wäre die bestehenden
Strukturen aufzuwerten und auch er
kritisierte die von der Ampel geplante
Zentralstelle Zitat was auf keinen Fall
funktionieren wird ist sich mit einer
Art intellektuellen kopfbehörde aus auf
Amtshilfe ersuchen zu verlassen und der
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Professor
Winkler fasste zusammen Zitat in
vielerlei Hinsicht enttäuscht dieser
Entwurf uns alle die wir im
sanktionsbereich Arbeiten massiv
und auch das Presseecho der Anhörung war
eindeutig ein Zitat Zentralstelle für
sanktionsdurchsetzung stößt auf
Ablehnung um nur ein Beispiel zu nennen
breite Ablehnung also für ihre
strukturvorschläge es gab dann doch eine
einzige Sachverständige die hat das
Gesetz nicht verbal zerrissen nämlich
die general soll Direktion zufällig
genau die Stelle bei der die Ampel diese
generalstelle in diese Zentralstelle
zunächst ansiedeln will und sogar diese
general soll Direktion baut für den Fall
des Scheiterns schon einmal vor sie sagt
Zitat allerdings sehen wir
Schwierigkeiten aufgrund des relativ
kurzen Zeitpunktes zudem die
Arbeitsfähigkeit gesichert sein soll sie
tat Ende und weiter führt sie dann aus
Zitat für diese Aufgabe existiert kein
speziell ausgebildetes Personal da diese
Aufgabe hat vollständig neu ist
also diejenigen die die Aufgaben nach
Wunsch der Ampel übernehmen sollen
Schrauben die Erwartungen schon einmal
nach ganz ganz unten mit der
sanktionsdurchsetzung geht es mit der
Ampel jedenfalls nicht voran so meine
Damen und Herren jetzt ist es so weiß
wie so weit wie ich ihn angekündigt habe
verlassen wir kurz den Bundestag für die
Pressekonferenz des Kanzlers mit dem
Nato-Generalsekretär jenzis Stoltenberg
sie haben sich gestern schon getroffen
bei der Berliner sicher Konzer
Sicherheitskonferenz wollen heute die
haben heute die Gespräche fortgesetzt es
geht wohl unter anderem um eine
Initiative Deutschlands und Norwegens
für die von NATO für eine von der NATO
geleitete Koordinierungsstelle zum
Schutz kritischer Unterwasser
Infrastruktur
Folgen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
das wird für die SPD-Fraktion hat der
Kollege ins zimmermann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Hintermänner und Organisationen des
russischen Präsidenten dürfen sich in
Deutschland finanziell nicht mehr sicher
führen und deshalb werden wir heute auch
mit den Stimmen der Ampel des zweite
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz beschließen
und damit
suchen wir auch den Schulterschluss mit
unseren europäischen Partnern als
Reaktion auf den brutalen angriffskriegs
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und es ist
eben wichtig die Finanzierung des
Krieges zu erschweren Zulieferung auch
von Kriegsmaterial zu unterbinden und
den Verantwortlichen russischen
politischen elitenfinanziell zu schaden
und deswegen braucht es auch diese
Sanktionen doch Sanktionen können nur
Wirkung entfalten wenn sie auch
entschlossen durchgesetzt werden und
zwar in dem Vermögenswert ermittelt und
sanktionierten Personen am Ende dann
auch zugeordnet werden können liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wie wichtig wie wichtig das ist
sehen wir ja dieser Tage die Recherchen
die in der aktuellen Ausgabe der Zeit zu
sehen sind über einen durchaus
bekannteren Landmaschinenhersteller aus
Deutschland die zeigen ja das ist nach
wie vor auch Versuche gibt jegliche
Formen von Sanktionen zu umgehen und das
eben auch auf dieser finanziellen Ebene
dieser Krieg weiter tobt und deswegen
ist es sehr sehr wichtig dass wir hier
in Deutschland Strukturen schaffen die
das am Ende auch erschweren und am
besten auch verhindern liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und dazu das haben wir vor
allem auch den Ländern zugesagt schaffen
wir eine bundeszuständigkeit eine
Bundesbehörde und da will ich schon mal
ganz klar sagen wir haben aktuell eine
fragmentierte Zuständigkeit über 16
Bundesländer wo sich am Ende keiner so
wirklich sicher ist ob da momentan
überhaupt irgendetwas durchgesetzt wird
und deswegen schaffen wir hier eine
Behörde auf Bundesebene mit über 100
Stellen und das hinzubekommen zu sagen
dass das nicht effektiv ist Herr Kollege
das muss man erstmal hinkriegen
ja wir schaffen eine neue zusätzliche
Behörde genau das tun wir und genau das
ist angezeigt an dieser Stelle weil man
muss ja eins sagen das haben sie sie
haben ja sehr viele Zitate gebracht es
wäre ja mal interessant gewesen von
ihnen selbst was zu hören als dass sie
immer nur andere für sich sprechen
lassen und ich habe das auf jeden Fall
notiert dass sie jetzt ein großer Fan
der Gewerkschaften sind dass sie jetzt
ein großer Fan von transparent sie
international sind ich werde sie beide
passende Gelegenheit daran erinnern Herr
Kollege weil das ist doch verräterisch
wenn Sie hier angeführt haben
wenn wir uns darüber hinaus anschauen
was eben alles damit passieren wird die
Länder werden entlastet und das ist eine
klare Verabredung die wir auch getroffen
haben es ist sehr sehr wichtig dass wir
klare verwaltungsvorhaben haben klare
Verwaltungsverfahren was den Zugriff auf
die Register angeht und wir schaffen es
endlich in diesem zweiten
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz ein
bargeldverbot für den Erwerb von
Immobilien einzuführen dass ein großer
Schritt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und da muss ich doch auch mal sagen ja
da kommen auch häufig ExpertInnen
Experten und auch viele Menschen und
fragen warum eigentlich erst jetzt warum
konnte ich denn bisher mit einem
Geldkoffer eine Immobilie hier in Berlin
kaufen warum haben sie das in acht
Jahren großer Koalition eigentlich nicht
hinbekommen naja da hätten sie mal
lieber auf transparent sie international
gehört Herr Kollege aber da war das
irgendwie gerade nicht Oper tun
und darüber hinaus haben wir eingeführt
der oder werden wir einführen das
Mitteilungspflichten von
Gesellschaften aus dem Ausland endlich
kommen weil auch das ist wichtig und in
Zukunft haben wir eben nicht nur das
Verbot von Barzahlungen sondern es ist
auch nicht möglich dass mit Gold zu
bezahlen und ja wir haben in der
Protokollerklärung auch noch aufgeführt
dass mit Silber und Kupfer das nicht
passieren soll wenn Sie das stört finde
ich nicht schlimm aber ich finde es
trotzdem sinnvoll lieber Kollege
wichtig ist aber auch das kann nur der
Auftakt sein und deswegen hat sich die
Ampel auch zu weitergehenden Maßnahmen
verpflichtet wir wollen eine digitale
immobilientransaktionsdatenbank
gemeinsam mit den notarinnen und Notaren
aufbauen umtransparenz reinzubringen
welche Immobilien eigentlich von wem an
wen den Besitzer wechseln und lassen Sie
mich das auch sagen wir haben das auch
in unserem Entschließungsantrag noch mal
aufgeführt obwohl man sagen könnte
braucht es eigentlich nicht wir wollen
dass die Länder bei der Digitalisierung
der Grundbücher endlich noch mal eine
Schippe drauflegen das kann nicht sein
dass wir immer wieder daran scheitern
dass wir Seiten haben die noch in
sütterlinge geschrieben sind aber damit
eben nicht arbeiten können und wir
nehmen den Ländern mit dieser neuen
Behörde viel Arbeit ab und deswegen
wünsche ich mir dass es bei der
Digitalisierung der Grundbücher eben
auch voran geht und Datenbanken sind in
diesem Thema in diesem Themenfeld
natürlich eine große eine große Sache
und deswegen sagen wir auch wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir stärker vorhandene
Daten besser miteinander und
datenschutzkonform zusammenführen können
denn wenn wir wüssten was wir alles
wissen dann würden wir vielen dieser
Oligarchen die wir hier treffen wollen
auch viel besser auf die Schliche kommen
meine Damen und Herren
für mehr Gerechtigkeit in unserem Land
sondern wir unterstützen auch die
Ukraine für ihren Kampf um
Selbstbestimmung und Freiheit und genau
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir dieses
zweite sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz
heute und hier verabschieden werden
herzlichen Dank
der nächste Redner ist kein Gottschalk
für die AFD
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren zunächst mal
danke an Matthias Hauer er hat glaube
ich sehr gut die Dysfunktionalität
dieses Gesetzes die few lässt grüßen für
die Insider gut dargestellt und dass sie
nicht mehr die Partei der Bürgerrechte
sind werde ich jetzt zum folgenden
darlegen aber bevor ich zu sprechen
komme auf das eigentliche Gesetz möchte
ich auch kurz auf den Antrag der cdu/csu
eingehen grundsätzlich könnten wir
nämlich mit den meisten Punkten mitgehen
Punkt 5 des Antrages allerdings halten
wir für Grund falsch sie wollen ich
zitiere mit der Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin die Grundlage dafür
geschaffen wird gemäß Paragraph 18
sanktions durchsetzungsgesetz
eingezogenes Vermögen zu verwerten und
den Erlös für den Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine zu verwenden es bedarf also
zunächst mal zweier Gesetze überhaupt um
die Sanktion umsetzbar zu machen sie
haben es eben dargestellt mit einem
riesigen Personal und Geldaufwand und
dann sollen sozusagen sozusagen die
Erlöse auch noch weitergegeben werden
ziemlich zu den bereits bestehenden
Hilfen wahrscheinlich mit diesem Blick
auf die aktuellen Krisen lehnen wir das
ab der Zweck heiligt eben nicht jedes
Mittel meine lieben Kollegen der cdu/csu
kommen wir aber zum eigentlichen
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz oder
entmündigungs- und vollständigen
Transparenz und Lesern und Bürgergesetz
so müsste man das eigentlich nennen denn
wir verstehen sicher den Sinn der
Erinnerung das ist schon ziemlich klar
dass sie hier planen da wo Sanktionen
erlassen werden na klar egal wie
sinnvoll diese Sanktionen sind und gegen
wen sie sich eigentlich wenden müssen
sie durchgesetzt werden dafür sie haben
es erwähnt soll eine Zentralstelle die
genauso dysfunktional ist wie die fio
etabliert werden mit viel Geld
allerdings noch fehlenden Haut aber wir
alle kennen ja das Sprichwort das in
etwa besagt der Weg in die Hölle ist
immer mit guten Absichten geflastert und
so meine Damen und Herren es ist auch
hier warum ab wann ist man in Olli egal
ich liebe Kollegen der SPD ab welchem
Vermögen bis wann muss mein Herr Putin
seine Partei oder Russland etwa
unterstützt haben oder toleriert haben
bis zum 24 Februar 22 und eine Frage
direkt an Sie Herr Rudi was machen Sie
denn mit dem genossen der mit Herrn
Schröder muss der sein Haus in Hannover
auch abgeben weil er ziemlich lange zu
Herrn Putin gehalten hat und bei Gast
kommen für gute Geschäfte gesorgt hat
wollen sie auch Herrn Schröder auf die
Oligarchen sesseliste setzen das zeigt
auch eigentlich wie wirklich die
Demokratie feindlich ihr Gesetz ist
lassen Sie es an der Stelle oder nehmen
Sie Herrn Schröder gleich mit auf meine
sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren der ampelregierung und
das ist jetzt was allgemeines ein so
scharfes Schwert ich habe es eben
aufgezeigt weil du mich irgendeine
Kommission festlegt wer kommt auf diese
Liste gehört nicht in ihre Hände
beispiele gefällig sie verwehren hier im
Hohen Hause der afd-fraktion bis heute
den zuständigen Vizepräsidenten Posten
in den Ausschüssen wählen Sie uns die
zustehenden Vorsitzenden nicht sie war
brav brauchen den Verfassungsschutz als
regierungsschutz auch hier nehmen Sie
dann und denen Sie dann die Gesetze so
weit dass sich die Balken liegen jeder
AFD nahestehende Partei Stiftung
bekommen bis heute kein Geld ihren sie
ihren Stiftung hier die Taschen voll
machen sie missbrauchen dass wenn wir
morgen
Jahressteuergesetz haben die 122 AOV
Energie ja das trifft sie wie
geschlagene Hunde ich weiß die Energie
notfallordnung um eine übergewinnsteuer
auszubringen da haben die
Verfassungsrechtler gesagt wir haben
große Bedenken unterhalten waren das
zeigt eigentlich wie sie sind erklärt
wagenkleber zu heiligen während
corona-kritiker die gegen ihre Maßnahmen
auf die Straße gehen und friedlich
demonstrieren zu Staatsfeinden erklärt
worden meine Damen und Herren sie sehen
also diese ampelregierung der fehlt es
ein Anstand Moral als auch in der
politischen Reife ein solches
sanktionsetzungsgesetz zwei überhaupt in
ihre Hände zu bekommen meine Damen und
Herren mit diesem Gesetz wird dem
Missbrauch und gerade in ihren Händen
Türen Tor geöffnet und ich möchte genau
sie alle heute davor waren und es auch
sagen damit niemanden ein paar Jahren
sagen kann wo von diesem Missbrauch
meine Damen und Herren auf den Tribünen
da haben wir ja gar nichts das lassen
ausgleichsgesetz wird kommen das lässt
auch hier mit Grüßen und aus dieser
demokratischen Veranstaltung da ziehen
sie sind weit über die Redezeit weil
unsere Sekunden
mit Recht ablehnen danke
[Applaus]
bruno hat jetzt das Wort für Bündnis 90
die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lange Zeit galt
Sanktion Verhängnis das eine Sanktion
durchsetzen das andere und man muss es
so deutlich sagen Deutschland war ein
Paradies für oligarchenvermögen und
schmutziges Geld aus aller Welt die
Zahlen zeigen aber dass sich das nun
langsam ändert 18,9 Milliarden Euro
russische Vermögenswerte wurden laut
Kommissionen der EU bereits eingefroren
2,2 Milliarden Euro davon in Deutschland
das ist gut es ist jetzt unsere Pflicht
in Solidarität mit der Ukraine die
gezielten Sanktion umzusetzen und
unseren Beitrag zu leisten und Putins
Regime wirtschaftlich so Schwächen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und zur
Wahrheit gehört eben auch dazu dass sie
von der Union es waren die Deutschland
erst zu diesem geldwäscheparadies haben
werden lassen sie haben Geldwäsche und
Co jahrelang als Kavaliersdelikt
behandelt und eben keine wirksame
Maßnahmen zur Bekämpfung der Geldwäsche
ergriffen und deswegen ist sind ihre
Kritik gerade vor dem Hintergrund ihrer
eigenen Untätigkeit auch so
unglaubwürdig liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
von der Union vieles von dem was wir im
sdg2 zur effektiven Durchsetzung von
Sanktionen beschließen das hätten sie
bereits vor Jahren umsetzen müssen haben
sie aber nicht es brauchte hier eine
Ampelkoalition um endlich voranzukommen
und deswegen bin ich froh dass wir die
effektive Durchsetzung von Sanktionen
jetzt endlich angehen und gleichzeitig
über unseren Entschließungsantrag noch
mal klar machen dass wir im kommenden
Jahr schon in der ersten Jahreshälfte
ein Paket zur Bekämpfung von Geldwäsche
verabschieden werden und da werden wir
den fltf Empfehlungen Rechnung tragen
und klar machen das Geldwäsche und Co
eben keine kavaliersste legte sind
sondern Straftaten und dass wir sie
genauso auch behandeln und konsequent
verfolgen werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir bündeln nun endlich die
Maßnahmen zu sanktions Durchsetzung in
einem eigenen Gesetz konkret schaffen
wir neue Instrumente und verschärfen
bestehende Mechanismen in der
Vergangenheit konnten weder öffentliche
Stellen noch am Mittler in vielen Fällen
sagen wer der Ware Eigentümer einer
Immobilie in Deutschland ist das ändert
sich jetzt wir legen den Grundstein für
ein immobilienregister indem wir
Immobiliendaten mit dem
Transparenzregister verknüpfen wir
führen endlich ein barzahlungsverbot ein
dass wir auch auf Edelmetalle erweitert
haben und wir verpflichten alle
ausländischen Gesellschaften die aktuell
in Deutschland Immobilien haben ihre
Waren Eigentümer entsprechend anzugeben
das ist ein riesiger längst überfälliger
Schritt für mehr Transparenz auf den
Immobilienmarkt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und auch bei der Verschleierung mittels
juristischer Gesellschaften und
Briefkastenfirmen sind wir dran gegen
den Missbrauch sogenannte fiktiver
wirtschaftlich Berechtigter wird jetzt
entschieden vorgegangen sie sehen wir
haben nicht nur ein klares Ziel und ein
konkreten Plan sondern wir zeigen auch
mit den entsprechenden Gesetzen das mit
dem geldwäscheparadies Deutschland
endlich Schluss sein muss und dafür
legen wir mit dieser gesetzlichen
Grundlage den entsprechenden Grundstein
herzlichen Dank liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Pascal Meise hat das Wort für die Linke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren vorweg Herr Gottschalk
sie haben heute wieder eindrücklich
bewiesen warum die AFD wirklich die
einzig wahre Alternative für Oligarchen
und Geldwäsche in diesem Hause ist das
haben sie wieder deutlich gemacht
aber zum Gesetzentwurf den wir heute
hier abschließend beraten damit wollte
die Bundesregierung endlich für die
dringend notwendigen Verbesserungen
Kampf gegen Geldwäsche und bei der
Durchsetzung von Sanktionen gegen
russische Oligarchen sorgen doch selbst
dringliche Probleme werden damit leider
weiter nicht gelöst weiterhin drücken
sich davor die private Nutzung von
sanktionierten Vermögen zu untersagen
und ich wiederhole mich hier gerne es
ist und bleibt niemanden zu vermitteln
dass ein sanktionierten Oligarchen in
Deutschland zu untersagt ist seine führt
will Villa in Berlin Zehlendorf oder am
Steinberger See zu vermieten er sie mal
weiterhin uneingeschränkt und ganz legal
selbst privat nutzen darf meine Damen
und Herren
hinzu kommt dass eine Auskunft der
Bundesbank Vermögen dass ein
funktionierte Oligarchen einzelnen
Unternehmen geparkt hat im Regelfall
nicht eingefroren ist auch hier trauen
sich nicht ran darauf auf diesem Wege
bleibt so also es ein Leichtes die
eigentlich bestehenden
vermögensanktionen zu gehen auch das ist
doch niemandem zu ermitteln meine Damen
und Herren aber
es ist ja gut dass die Ampelkoalition
zumindest erkannt hat dass die Probleme
tiefer liegen und es ist klar dass die
Versäumnisse der vergangenen Jahre bei
der Geldwäsche Bekämpfung nicht
innerhalb weniger Monate vollständig
aufzuarbeiten sind man muss dazu an
dieser Stelle vielleicht aber auch noch
mal daran erinnern dass ich noch 2019
der damalige Bundesfinanzminister ein
gewisser Olaf Scholz mit Händen und
Füßen gegen ein bargeldverbot bei
Immobilien geholfen gewährt hat gut dass
ich das jetzt endlich ändert
und ja sie wollen endlich auch für mehr
Transparenz sorgen dann ist darum geht
wem eigentlich in Unternehmen gehört gut
so aber ich prophezeihen sie werden
scheitern wenn sie nicht schnell auch
dafür sorgen dass falsche Einträge ins
Transparenzregister systematisch
identifiziert werden ein Blick nach
Österreich verrät ist besser geht dort
im Transparenzregister liegt die
eintragungsquote bei fast 100%, das mit
minimalen personellen Aufwand
wer dort falsche oder unzureichende
Angaben macht begeht nach
österreichischem Recht sogar eine
Straftat von der all dem sind wir
hierzulande noch immer weit entfernt das
doch Realität meine Damen und Herren
warum greifen Sie hier nicht zumindest
den Vorschlag des Bundesrats auf ein
geschäftsverbot für diejenigen
Unternehmen auszusprechen lieber
verschachtelte firmenkonstruktion ihre
Waren Eigentümer verschleiern
und wenn sie wirklich an die Wurzeln des
Problems wollen dann müssen Sie jetzt
schnell eine Rechtsgrundlage dafür
schaffen Verdächtige großvermögen
ungeklärter Herkunft einzuführen und als
ultima ratio auch beschlagnahmen zu
können fehlt ist trotz behördlicher
Aufforderung an der plausiblen Erklärung
woher verdächtiges Vermögen stammt ist
es einzuziehen Punkt so wie dies zum
Beispiel Großbritannien mit der
anexplaint-welve Order versucht ich
komme zum Schluss leider machen sie es
Drogenbossen Waffenhändlern
Steuerbetrüger nicht zuletzt russischen
Oligarchen noch immer viel zu einfach
die Geschäft und Vermögen zu
verschleiern das ist schlecht auch wenn
ihr Bemühen durchaus erkennbar ist hören
Sie einfach den Rat der Praktiker
wischen Sie die zahlreichen Vorschläge
der Bundesländer nicht beiseite und
nehmen Sie schnellsten einen neuen
Anlauf damit künftig tatsächlich
konsequent gegen verdächtiges Vermögen
vorgegangen werden kann vielen Dank
Carlos casper ist der nächste Redner für
die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja Deutschland
ist noch ein geldwäscheparadies und ist
setzt auch ungenügend die Sanktionen
gegen russische Oligarchen und andere
gelistete Personen um aber warum ist
denn das so Herr Hauer weil wir leider
mit Ihnen diese die 16 Jahre regiert
haben und sie sich jedes Mal vor
Geldwäscher und besonders gleichen
geworfen haben und diese Leute zu
schützen
die fortschrittskoalition macht sich
jetzt auf so meine Damen und Herren sind
wir wieder zurück im Bundestag hier wird
immer noch über das Sanktion zu
durchsetzungsgesetze diskutiert also im
weitesten Sinne auch noch mal das
thematisiert was auch
Gesprächsteil war zwischen Olaf Scholz
und Jens Stoltenberg nämlich der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine am Pult ist
Carlos Casper aus der SPD-Fraktion und
das hier unter anderem auch um die Rolle
des Zeus geht scheint mir ganz
angebracht ihn auch noch zu erzählen
dass Carlos Casper vor seiner Zeit im
Bundestagswahl Beamter gewesen ist jetzt
ist er Mitglied im Finanzausschuss
Gesellschaften oder die GmbHs verfügen
und damit auch über die Immobilie und
das wollen wir ändern wir verpflichten
hier die Notare endlich Immobiliendaten
an das
Transparenzregister zu melden
und damit gewinnen wir erstmals einen
Überblick darüber wem welche Immobilien
Deutschland gehört und haben
gleichzeitig im Transparenzregister die
Verknüpfung wer über diese Immobilien
verfügt
Punkt 2 in Deutschland konnte man bisher
alles aber auch wirklich alles mit
Bargeld bezahlen man konnte teurer Autos
Schmuck Uhren kaufen und eben auch
Immobilien
das verhindern wir jetzt wir setzen ein
bargeldverbot bei Immobilien Käufen ein
und im parlamentarischen Verfahren
konnten wir diese dieses bargeldverbot
nochmals verschärfen zusätzlich ist es
jetzt verboten auch mit Gold mit Platin
oder mit Edelsteinen Immobilien zu
kaufen und ja die SPD hätte sich da auch
noch mehr gewünscht darauf auf
europäische Ebene umgesetzt und Punkt 3
wir hatten bisher leider noch keine
wirkliche Behörde die für sie
sanktionsdurchsetzung ordinär zuständig
war im sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetz eins
haben wir das erst deswegen noch mal
klargestellt dass die Länder hier
eigentlich in der Verantwortung sind und
dieser Klarstellung war aber eben auch
ein Versprechen angeführt das
Versprechen dass wir die
bundeszuständigkeit übernehmen und
dieses Gesetz erklärt nun dass wir eine
Zentralstelle für sanktions Durchsetzung
einführen werden und diese neue Behörde
wird in der General sollte Situation
gegründet werden und ja es gab Kritik
und
es gab nicht nur Kritik aber es gab
Kritik und die Öffentlichkeit hat jetzt
den Anspruch dass Christian Lindner und
das Bundesfinanzministerium dafür sorgt
dass diese Zentralstelle wirklich die
Sanktionen durchsetzen wird
diese drei Punkte die verbesserten
Immobiliendaten ein bargeldverbot bei
Immobilienkäufen und eben diese
Zentralstelle für sanktionsdurchsetzung
sind große Bausteine mit vielen weiteren
kleinen Bausteinen die wir jetzt auf den
Weg bringen gehen wir wichtige Schritte
hin zur einer besseren
Geldwäschebekämpfung und zu einer
besseren sanktionsdurchsetzung aber uns
ist auch klar dass wir noch weitere
Schritte gehen müssen und deswegen legen
wir heute auch noch einen
Entschließungsantrag vor dieser sieht
vor dass wir ein Immobilien
transaktionsdatenbank einführen wir
machen Druck bei der Digitalisierung der
Grundbücher und verknüpfen auch
weiterhin Register und ja ich bin auch
stolz dass wir auch für uns für ein
Instrument aussprechen das ist
ermöglicht Vermögen unklarer Herkunft
einzuziehen und gegebenenfalls auch zu
verwerten wenn eben der Eigentümer nicht
erklären kann wo dieses Vermögen
herkommt
sie sehen die fortschrittskoalition ist
gewillt effizient gegen Geldwäsche
vorzugehen und die Sanktionen
durchzusetzen wir legen Stein für Stein
um eben kein Paradies mehr zu sein für
Geld ist vielen Dank
Carlos Kasper in der Debatte des
Bundestags zum sanktions
durchsetzungsgesetz 2 also die zweite
Stufe um Sanktionen gegen Russland bzw
russische olympischen besser durchsetzen
zu können es liegt ein Antrag der Union
vor die möchte eine zollpolizei eine
schlagkräftige wie sie sagt um da
effektiver in Zukunft zu sein mal
schauen was Susanne hirl aus der
Unionsfraktion dazu sagen
Verbesserungen in der sanktions
Durchsetzung und der Bekämpfung der
Geldwäsche bringen es ist vorgesehen
eine Zentralstelle für
sanktionsdurchsetzung auf Bundesebene im
Geschäftsbereich des
Bundesfinanzministeriums einzurichten so
sollen Synergieeffekte bei der sanktions
Durchsetzung und der Geldwäsche erreicht
werden
bei der Zentralstelle geht es
wohlgemerkt und das haben wir heute
schon öfter gehört um eine neue Behörde
die noch einzurichten wäre damit
ignoriert die Ampel die Ausführungen der
Experten mehrere Sachverständige
darunter der Bund der Deutscher
Kriminalbeamter oder die Gewerkschaft
der Polizei haben aufgezeigt dass die
Schaffung einer völlig neuen Behörde
wieder notwendig noch praktikabel oder
zielführend sei
sie empfehlen viel mehr auf die
bestehenden Strukturen und die Erfahrung
des Zolls zurückzugreifen und diese
Strukturen zu verbessern unsere Ansicht
nach sollte das schlussendlich in einer
Bundes-
der Zoll könnte im Gegensatz zu einer
völlig neuen Behörde außerdem sofort mit
der Suche nach sanktionierten Vermögen
beginnen es würde keine weitere
wertvolle Zeit vergeudet so könnten sie
die Synergien Erreichen von welchen sie
in ihrer Gesetzesbegründung sprechen in
ihrem Koalitionsvertrag formulieren Sie
das here Ziel die Praxis und die
betroffenen Kreise der Gesellschaft in
die Gesetzgebung mit einzubeziehen und
dabei nehmen sie in diesem Fall nicht
einmal die Anregungen der
Sachverständigen auf in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag haben Sie sich
eigentlich auch vorgenommen denn soll
moderner aufzustellen damit er die
Finanzkriminalität besser verfolgen kann
weiter wollen sie den Zoll im Rahmen der
Bekämpfung der Geldwäsche Stärken dieses
Gesetz werde die Möglichkeit dazu
gewesen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Kollegen der Ampel der Aufbau einer
neuen Behörde die noch dazu auf die
Verfolgung von sanktionierten Vermögen
beschränkt bleibt sprich da eine andere
Sprache
halten wir also fest sie halten sich
nicht an Ihre Vorgaben aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag und vergeuden dazu
noch wertvolle Zeit und Steuergelder
im übrigen wäre es sinnvoll gewesen alle
Regelungen die sich auf die Sanktionen
und Geldwäsche beziehen in einem Gesetz
kompakt und übersichtlich mit gleicher
Terminologie zusammenzufassen statt
Änderungen in 20 Gesetzen vorzunehmen
was mich zu einem weiteren Thema bringt
wenn sie schon die Regelungen nicht
vereinheitlichen und sie daher über 20
Gesetze ändern müssen dann sollten sie
wenigstens ihr Versprechen aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag einlösen und ihrem
Gesetzentwürfen sind beilegen das würde
uns allen das Arbeiten sehr erleichtern
sinnvoll wäre es auch gewesen eine
Beweislastumkehr bei Vermögen mit
ungeklärter Herkunft einzuführen damit
müsste der Eigentümer eines solchen
Vermögens dessen Herkunft nachweisen
kann er das nicht wird das Vermögen
eingefroren auch ist nicht
nachvollziehbar wieso sie kein
Nutzungsverbot für eingefrorene
Vermögensgegenstände aussprechen über
eingefrorenes Geld auf dem Konto kann
der sanktionierte nicht mehr verfügen
seine Villa am Starnberger See oder die
Yacht kann er dem Gegenüber weiterhin
benutzen diese unterschiedliche
Behandlung ist nicht gerechtfertigt und
auch nicht verständlich
auch auf die Frage was eigentlich mit
den eingefrorenen Vermögensgegenständen
geschieht geben Sie keine Antwort in
ihrem Gesetzentwurf wir sind der Meinung
dass es verfassungskonforme Regelungen
Bedarf die die Einziehung und Verwertung
des sanktionierten Vermögens möglich
machen können im besten Fall kann dieses
Vermögen zum Wiederaufbau in der Ukraine
verwendet werden dazu bedarf es aber
gesonderter Regelungen mein Fazit zum
vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf zur
umständlich zu zaghaft und nicht zu Ende
gedacht daher bleibt uns trotz einiger
guter Ansätze nur die Ablehnung
herzlichen Dank
sagt Susanne Hierl aus der
Unionsfraktion zum Vorhaben
sanktions-durchsetzungsgesetz zwei der
Ampelkoalition und für die spricht jetzt
noch mal Marcel Emmerich aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen das ist
ja Obmann im Innenausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren ich möchte zum Abschluss der
Debatte noch mal drei wesentliche Punkte
deutlich machen aus meiner Sicht
erstens wir können feststellen und
erfreut an dieser Stelle das durch diese
ganze Frage von
oligarchentum und Sanktionen
Durchsetzung eine sehr große Dynamik in
den Kampf gegen organisierte
Kriminalität gegen Geldwäsche gegen
Finanzkriminalität generell gekommen ist
und das ist ein längst überfälliges
Zeichen
seit langem
seit langem lag zum Beispiel die Idee
eines bargeldverbots für Immobilien auf
dem Tisch viele Menschen können sich
übrigens überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen
wie es ist eine Immobilie zu kaufen weil
sie gar nicht die finanziellen
Möglichkeiten haben das muss auch mal am
Rande gesagt werden und wenn man jetzt
mit Menschen auf der Straße spricht und
ihnen erzählt dass es bisher möglich war
mit Bargeld in einem Umschlag in einer
Tüte oder einem Koffer ein Haus zu
kaufen dann erntet man irritierte ja
schockierte Blicke und damit ist jetzt
Schluss Deutschland darf nicht die
Waschmaschine Europas sein wir sorgen
für echte Geldwäsche Bekämpfung
ein zweiter wichtiger Punkt den ich noch
anmerken möchte der eine Debatte noch
gar nicht vorkamen der Entwurf der aus
dem BMF vorgelegt hatte den haben wir im
parlamentarischen Verfahren gerade in
Hinblick auf den Datenschutz noch mal
verbessert wir haben ja die
Stellungnahme des BfDI berücksichtigt
und hier gerade was sie Regelungen
bezüglich des Registers betrifft eine
Präzisierung geschafft auch das will ich
an dieser Stelle nicht unerwähnt lassen
und dann
danke Kollege hertmann dann möchte ich
noch zum dritten Punkt etwas sagen und
zwar zu dieser Strukturdebatte die hier
jetzt sehr zentral war zum einen muss
man da noch mal schauen was es gerade
überhaupt auf dem Tisch über was wird
debattiert da ging es ja auch in der
Anhörung hin und her wir schaffen jetzt
eine Zentralstelle zu Durchsetzung der
Sanktion aber wenn man noch weiter denkt
dann liegt ja schon der Vorschlag von
Bundesfinanzminister Linden auf dem
Tisch hinsichtlich eines sogenannten
bundesfinanzkriminalamts und ich kann
nur für meine Fraktion sagen dass wir
die Vorschläge dass wir die Kritik die
in der Anhörung auch daran schon ja
vorgenommen wurde dass wir die auch im
weiteren Verlauf nicht unter den Tisch
fallen lassen die Struktur Debatte ist
mitnichten heute beendet sie geht
gewissermaßen gerade erst los
das heißt die Fragen BKA zkea BFK all
das liegt auf dem Tisch wir schauen uns
das genau an wie diskutieren das und
dass diese Behörde dann auch wirklich
schnell kommt haben wir auch mit einem
Entschließungsantrag im Finanzausschuss
noch mal festgezirrt das heißt wir als
Fraktion sind dahinter her das
zuständigkeitsbürger aufzulösen um
kriminellen Strukturen das Handwerk zu
legen ihnen das Geld zu entziehen egal
ob es um Putins klicke geht oder um
andere finanziellen kriminellen
Machenschaften in diesem Land vielen
Dank
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache
und wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
von den Koalitionsfraktionen
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
effektiveren Durchsetzung von Sanktionen
der Finanzausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache 47 27 den Gesetzentwurf
in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen ich
bitte diejenigen die in dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen die
koalitionsfraktion wer stimmt dagegen
CDU CSU und AFD wer enthält sich die
Linke dann ist der Gesetzentwurf in
zweiter Beratung angenommen und wir
kommen zur dritten Beratung unserer
Schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
sind die Koalitionsfraktionen vielen
herzlichen Dank
wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu und die AFD vielen Dank und er
enthält sich dass die Fraktion DIE LINKE
vielen Dank dann ist der Gesetzentwurf
damit angenommen unter Buchstabe d
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache 4727 empfiehlt der
Finanzausschuss eine Entschließung
anzunehmen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
die Linke die koalitionsfraktion wer
stimmt dagegen
die AFD wer enthält sich die cdu/csu
dann ist die Beschlussempfehlung damit
angenommen wir setzen die Abstimmung zu
der Beschlussempfehlung des
Finanzausschusses auf Drucksache 47 27
fort der Ausschuss empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe b seiner Beschlussempfehlung
den gleichlautenden Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung für erledigt zu erklären
wer stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
so da sind wir im Bereich von Formalia
deswegen können wir uns dem nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt widmen da wird es um
die wärmewende gehen es liegt zugrunde
einen Antrag der Unionsfraktion mit dem
Titel wärmewende versorgungssicher
nachhaltig und sozial gestalten und die
unionfraktion fordert die
Bundesregierung in diesem Antrag zu
insgesamt 20 Maßnahmen auf die im
Zusammenhang mit der wärmewende stehen
da sind dann aufgelistet etwa
Forderungen die energetische Sanierung
voranzutreiben Gasnetze weiter
auszubauen und zu ertüchtigen damit
diese sowohl für Biomethan als auch für
Wasserstoff genutzt werden können in den
Ausbau und die dekarbonisierung von fern
und Nahwärme soll investiert werden und
wenn ich mir das alles so hier in Ruhe
angucke da werden wir jetzt mal die
Stoppuhr stellen und auf den ersten
Redner warten der sagt warum habt ihr
Unionsfraktion das nicht schon in der
vergangenen Legislaturperiode erledigt
wir werden dann berichten wie lange es
gedauert hat der erste Redner in dieser
Debatte wird jedenfalls sein eine
aus der Unionsfraktion sie ist Mitglied
im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
und wir schauen uns ein bisschen im
Plenarsaal um hier ist noch etwas
Rotation im Gange denn die Experten aus
dem Bereich Inneres und Heimat verlassen
jetzt den Plenarsaal und die
Spezialisten für Wärme und Energie
Rücken nach vorne in die erste Reihe
jetzt ist der Tagesordnungspunkt von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin mag was auch
aufgerufen und eine König vorne am Pult
zweite Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wer alles auf
eine Karte setzt setzt alles aufs Spiel
bis zum Jahr 2045 will Deutschland
Klimaneutralität erreichen dafür setzen
wir uns mit unserem Antrag ein als
cdu/csu sind wir überzeugt nur mit einem
gelungenen Maßnahmenmix wird die
Mammutaufgabe wärmewende erfolgreich die
für die Klimaneutralität nötige
wärmewende muss Versorgungssicherheit
garantieren nachhaltig und bezahlbar
sein
aktuell heizen zum Beispiel 40 Millionen
Menschen also jeder zweite Haushalt mit
Gas die energetische Gebäudesanierung
kommt kaum über ein Prozent hinaus es
sieht schlecht aus darum fordern wir als
Union die wärmewende pragmatisch
anzugehen das heißt keine Beschränkung
auf nur eine Karte auf nur eine
Technologie auf nur eine Lösung die
wärmewende braucht viele Ideen und viele
Hände und sie braucht das Gespräch mit
allen Akteuren
was passiert wenn man nur auf eine Karte
setzt und sei es auch mit beste Absicht
das erleben wir ja alle seit dem
Ausbleiben der russischen Gaslieferung
leider nannte der Bundeskanzler in
seiner Haushaltsrede nur Sonne Wind und
Wasserstoff als Energiequellen es gibt
aber zwischen Himmel und Erdkern noch
viel mehr Optionen als die an die sich
der Kanzler erinnern kann dazu gehören
unter anderem Abwärme Geothermie Kraft
wärmekopplung Biogas lüftungstechnologie
die Wärme zurückgewinnt und so weiter
wir sind ein Volk von Ingenieuren und
Tüftlern und das müssen wir unbedingt
weiterhin nutzen damit die wärmewende
gelingt
doch statt alle Kräfte zu erreichen der
wärmewende zu bündeln wird gerade eine
ganze Branche der alternativen Energie
und Wärmeerzeugung zerstört in
Deutschland gibt es 9.600 Biogasanlagen
theoretisch könnten sie bereits heute
ein Drittel des Gasbedarfs decken sie
können Strom zu den Zeiten erzeugen in
denen Wind und Sonne nicht ausreichend
liefern mit der schlecht gemachten
erlös-abschöpfung der Ampel wird den
Biogasanlagen gerade ihr Grab
geschaufelt denn er löst Abschöpfung ist
eben nicht gleich übergewinn Abschöpfung
die Kosten für Biomasse sind sehr
gestiegen Gewinn ist bekanntlich das was
nach Abzug aller Kosten vom Erlös übrig
bleibt und wer wie sie Erlös und Gewinn
nicht voneinander unterscheiden kann hat
sich eigentlich für die weitere
energiepolitische Debatte völlig
disqualifiziert die Ampel zwingt die
Betreiber vom Biogasanlagen durch die
Erlös Abschöpfung in die Insolvenz
darüber hinaus werden Arbeitsplätze in
der herstellenden Industrie vernichtet
das Vertrauen der Investoren und
Unternehmer missbraucht ihr Umgang mit
der biogas-
hinzu kommt die von ihnen favorisierten
Wärmepumpen allein machen noch keine
wärmewende denn sie kosten fürs 1
Einfamilienhaus bereits mehrere 10.000
Euro die meist zusätzlich nötige
Wärmedämmung liegt auch im fünfstelligen
Bereich das mag sich ein Großteil der
Grünen Klientel leisten können das
Rentnerpaar in Rostock oder die Familie
mit Kindern die ihren Haus in Hagen noch
abbezahlt können sich das eben nicht
leisten und nicht nur der Preis nicht
nur die Tatsache dass wir nicht genügend
Strom für so viele Wärmepumpen haben
sind ein Problem aktuell sind nach
Schätzungen des Zentralverbandes Sanitär
Heizung und Klima nur etwa 30% der
installateurbetriebe überhaupt in der
Lage Wärmepumpen einzubauen und in
Betrieb zu nehmen gleichzeitig Fehlen
dieser Branche 60.000 Mitarbeiter
der Teilemangel bei den Herstellern
führt zudem zu langen Wartezeiten und so
dem so wird aus der Wärmepumpe schnell
auch mal eine wartepumpe und das alles
löst man auch nicht zentral per order
ph-beck ich sage es noch mal ganz
deutlich zu glauben es gäbe eine einzige
alleinselig machende Lösung und wir
hätten sie schon und deshalb alles auf
eine Karte zu setzen ist Grund falsch
und brandgefährlich
es gibt viel zu tun wir müssen alle
unsere Trümpfe ausspielen darum sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren bitte ich Sie
schon jetzt stimmen Sie unserem Antrag
zu die wärmewende braucht viele Hände
eine König mit einem Reim die wärmewende
braucht viele Hände weiß gar nicht ob
das beabsichtigt sein nächster Redner
ist ebenfalls im Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz und Energie und Timon
gremmels aus der SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren in der Tat ist die
wärmewende eines der wichtigsten Themen
die uns in dieser Periode auf der
Tagesordnung stehen deswegen finde ich
gut dass die cdu/csu sich damit
beschäftigt auch kritisch beschäftigt
mit den 16 Jahren wo sie für diese
Themen Verantwortung haben sie haben
eine schöne Bestandsaufnahme gemacht
Frau König über das was sie nicht
hinbekommen haben in den letzten 16
Jahren das was wir jetzt aufräumen
müssen das tun wir sehr gerne was mich
dann aber schon wundert ist wenn Sie
dieses Thema hier so prominent als ihren
Antrag auf die Weg bringen oder sie
keine zehn Abgeordneten der cdu/csu da
das zeigt ja wie wenig interessant das
Thema ist ich würde jetzt bei der PDF
bitten war Hund zu rufen dass auch
gleich ein paar mehr Leute da sind das
zeigt nämlich auch für die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer hier im
Deutschen Bundestag das ist eigentlich
für den Punkt dass cdu/csu das hier
selber beantragen sehr sehr schlechte
besucht sind meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren ich möchte mich aber auch
inhaltlich mit dem Thema beschäftigen
wir als weiße Ampelkoalition sind hier
die fortschrittskoalition wir bringen
die wärmewende nun wirklich voran wir
haben ein Ausbauprogramm für die
Wärmepumpen auf den Weg gebracht wir
wollen bis ab dem Jahre 2024 500.000
Wärmepumpen pro Jahr hinzubauen das ist
ein sehr ambitioniertes Ziel meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und es ist
auch sehr wichtig dass wir dieses tun
damit wir auch die wärmewende
voranbringen und ich habe mir in der
vorletzten Woche hatte ich das Vergnügen
mal einen Tag lang mit einem
Handwerker aus der Sanitär und
[Musik]
heizungs-pumpen verbaut hat wo er
kundenberatungsgespräche gemacht hat
woher auch informiert hat und das ist in
der Tat auch möglich in einem
Bestandsgebäude in Einfamilienhaus eine
Wärmepumpe einzubauen dass man das auch
wirtschaftlich betreiben kann und es ist
kein entweder oder meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren von der Union und von
mir Sie sich mal es macht auch Sinn
Hybrid Systeme einzubauen man kann auch
die bestehende Heizungsanlage ergänzen
ja das ist auch wichtig und genau das
funktioniert auch bei der Wärmepumpe
insofern ist das eine gute Technologie
die wir auch brauchen gerade in
Kombination mit einer Photovoltaikanlage
auf dem eigenen Dach mit dem Eigenstrom
die Wärmepumpe betreiben ist etwas
effizientes ist das kostensparnis und
ist der richtige Weg aber ich sage Ihnen
an dieser Stelle auch ich sage Ihnen an
dieser Stelle auch es ist nicht die
eierlegende Wollmilchsau die Wärmepumpe
allein wird die wärmewende nicht
voranbringen da bin ich ja bei Ihnen
Frau König deswegen müssen wir auch
gucken wo gibt es weitere Möglichkeiten
zum Beispiel auch bei der Fernwärme auch
dort kann man in einer Großstadt würde
ich jedem raten wenn er die Wahl hat
auch zu prüfen inwiefern eine Fernwärme
Anschluss eine Möglichkeit ist da gibt
es ja auch neue Wärmequellen zum
Beispiel auch die Abnahme der
Rechenzentren nutzen wie das in
Frankfurt getan wird durch den dortigen
Planungszeit
ich finde es ein sehr richtigen sehr
zukunftsgewandten Einwand und auch dort
zu gucken dass wir die Abwärme der
Rechenzentren die wie Pilze aus dem
Boden schießen auch nutzen um unsere
Wärmeversorgung voranzubringen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und wir
müssen in der Tat gucken dass wir bei
der Frage welche welches Heizungssystem
man sich entscheidet dass man dieses
verschiedenen Varianten auch
gleichberechtigt prüft und dass man auch
da technologieoffen ist und deswegen
wäre es schön wenn die beiden sehr
erfolgreichen
wärmepumpengipfel hinzu wärmegipfeln
weiterentwickelt werden meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren um dieses
Punkt diesen Punkt umfassend zu begehen
und wir müssen sicherstellen dass auch
im Falle einer Batterie wenn man jetzt
im Winter ein Ausfall der bestehenden
fossilen Heizung hat dass wir dann auch
kurzfristig helfen können weil die
derzeitigen
planungsvorläufe für die derzeitige
Beschaffung von Wärmepumpen ja
Lieferzeiten bis zu 6 Monaten wenn ich
kein länger vor sich haben und so lange
möchte keiner im Kalten sitzen deswegen
müssen wir gucken gibt es da Leasing mod
perfektes der Möglichkeit diese
kurzfristig auch zu unterstützen damit
sozusagen der Mangel an Wärmepumpen
nicht dazu führt dass man sich am Ende
des Tages wieder eine Ölheizung einbaut
oder eine Gasheizung sondern dass wir da
Dinge auf den Weg Klassen auf den Weg
bringen die das miteinander verbindet
und die auch solche Hybrid-Systeme
zulassen wichtig ist wenn wir so etwas
planen müssen wir das auch im Rahmen von
quartierskonzepten von kommunaler
wärmeplanung machen das ganz
entscheidend wichtig ist aber dass die
wärmewende wie auch die Energiewende
dezentral angelegt ist meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und ich sage
Ihnen an dieser Stelle wir müssen auch
bei diesem Thema hinein in die aus- und
Fortbildung in die Qualifizierung auch
des Handwerkers die Menschen im Handwerk
die Menschen im Eska Handwerk sind
bereit dazu stehen bereit wollen sich
auch auf diese Technologien einlassen
lassen sich darauf ein da müssen wir
aber auch gemeinsam auch mit dem
Handwerk die Ausbildung
erneuern weiterbringen Moder
organisieren wir müssen sie unterstützen
dabei und was unser Ziel ist wenn wir
das Thema Wärmepumpen in den Mittelpunkt
der Politik stellen möchte ich möchte
die Sozialdemokratie als die Partei auch
des industriellen Fortschrittes und der
regionalen Wertschöpfung das möglichst
viele dieser Wärmepumpen auch in
Deutschland produziert werden wir wollen
hier nicht unbedingt asiatische Energie
Wärmepumpe einbauen sondern wir möchten
das auch hier die deutschlandanbieter
die wir ja so viel haben in den
verschiedenen Regionen ich möchte jetzt
hier keine Namen nennen das wir auch
denen die Chance geben mit ihren guten
hightech-projekten und Produkten in die
Keller in die Heizungskeller der
Menschen zu kommen und deswegen ist auch
hier wie auch bei der Energiewende bei
der wärmewende es ganz entscheidend dass
wir regionale Wertschöpfung dass der
Industriepolitik machen und dass wir
hier die Produktion ausbauen
unterstützen und da ist diese Ampel eine
fortschrittkoalition wir gehen voran und
ich sehe der PDF war erfolgreich
aus der SPD-Fraktion und wir haben es ja
vorhergesagt zu Beginn dieser Debatte
hat dann doch keine fünf Minuten
gedauert bis der erste auf die vorherige
Legislaturperiode verwiesen hat und das
was aus in diesem Fall Timon Gremmel
Sicht die Union nicht gemacht hat beim
Thema Klimaschutz und
wärmewende jetzt haben wir Carsten Hilse
aus der afd-fraktion
Leute es wendet mal wieder in ihrem
Entwurf wird die Kollegen der Union und
wie allein zehnmal kommt das Wort
wärmewende in ihrem Antrag vor nach
Energiewende Agrarwende Verkehrswende
mobilitätswende soll nun auch die Wärme
gewendet werden eine Fraktion voller
wendehilfe wenige Abgeordnete
ausdrücklich ausgenommen laut Wiki also
Personen die ihre Gesinnung stets der
aktuellen politischen Lage ohne eigene
Überzeugung anpassen doch wohin wenn sie
nach 16 Jahren Regierungsverantwortung
unter der verantwortungslosen
skrupellosen und nun mehr
glücklicherweise ex-kanzlerin und
zahllosen wenden haben sie immer noch
nicht begriffen dass alle ihre wenden
allesamt im Nichts enden
voran die Mutter aller wenden die
Energiewende ins Nichts wie es Professor
Hans Werner sind und längst zu treffen
formulierte sie haben immer noch nicht
begriffen dass ihre wenden allesamt
eines zum Ziel haben und nur eines
erreichen nämlich alles was dieses Land
stark und wohlhabend gemacht hat zu
verteuern zu verbieten und zu vernichten
und alles was die Bürger mit ihrem Fleiß
ihre Intelligenz ihre Kompetenz ihre
Schaffenskraft erbaut haben auf dem
Altar der Grünen Klimareligion zu opfern
alle ihre wenden fußen auf der absurden
und von tausenden Wissenschaftlern
widersprochenen Annahme dass die
menschengemachten CO2-Emissionen des
Klima maßgeblich beeinflussen und es
wird ja noch absurder selbst wenn man
diesen unwissenschaftlichen Unsinn
glaubte ist der Einfluss Deutschlands
marginal selbst unter den schlimmsten
Annahmen also der höchsten angenommenen
Klimasensitivität von CO2 und der
längsten Verweildauer in der Atmosphäre
würde Deutschland wenn es von heute auf
morgen kein einziges Gramm CO2 mehr
ausstoßen würde die hypothetische
Erderwärmung um 0,0
0 5 6 2 Grad verringern ich weiß für die
Spezialisten auf der linken Seite sind
solche Fachbegriffe wie
Klimasensitivität und Verweildauer in
der Atmosphäre eher verwirrend deswegen
wende ich mich an die CDU da ist
zumindest ein höheres geistliches Niveau
zu vermuten allerdings haben sie es in
diesem Antrag verstanden dieses
vermutete Niveau nicht abzurufen da ist
im Antrag die Rede oder sollte man
besser sagen der wird geschwollen
geschwafelt das stromgetriebene
Wärmepumpen sozusagen aus dem Nichts die
Wärmeversorgung übernehmen sollen mit
Strom den wir auch dank ihrer Politik
bald nicht nur nicht mehr haben sondern
wenn wir ihn dann bekommen diesen für
Otto Normalverbraucher und bezahlbar ist
da wird davon geschlafen ein Luftschloss
auf das andere zu setzen wenn Sie zum
Beispiel
wärmewende real Labore einrichten oder
Energiespeicher die aber leider noch
erfunden werden müssen denn die
verhandelnden Energiespeicher wie Kohle
Öl Gas oder Uran lehnen sehr lässt
schlussendlich ab und wollen sie so wie
die Grünen komm stattdessen auch als
bald aus ihnen aussteigen was also soll
das entweder Sie haben ausgereift
erprobte Produkte und Verfahren
Verfahren die besser und möglichst auf
billiger sind als die bestehenden und
führen die auf breiter Front ein dann
geht jede Wende von selbst oder und das
ist ihr weg und das ist der Weg des
gesamten Hauses die haben das nicht
stattdessen bauen sie einen luftschluss
nach dem anderen denn das realabore
grünen Wasserstoff oder einfach
erneuerbare Energien hauptsache es
klingt gut dazu füttern Sie dann noch
die Erbauer von vogelschreddern und die
Märchenerzähler in den Meer die in den
Medien mit teuren Subventionen erzielen
den Menschen im Himmel des Jahrmarkt und
vernichten dann konsequent und parallel
die gesamte vorhandene noch
funktionierende Wirtschaft schöpfende
Infrastruktur Deutschlands und mit ihren
Millionen von Arbeitsplätzen ihr Antrag
dient der Zerstörung Deutschlands er
soll sie beschleunigen sie soll wollen
gemeinsam mit den Grünen Kommunisten
unser Land auf dem Altar der Klima
Religion
Opfern dazu werden wir weder Ihnen noch
sonst jemanden jemals unsere stimm
gegeben sondern sie mit ihrer
klimaschutzideologie auf jede
demokratische und legale Art und Weise
bekämpfen ich bedanke mich für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
und verbindest 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort der Kollege Bernhard Herrmann und
Bernhard Herrmann ist Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja werde
Energiewende genutzt hat merkt davon
Wasser an Nutzen hat für Klimaschutz von
eigenen Geldbeutel für die Entlastung
das wollen sie die Menschen nicht können
das ist schon klar aber zu ihnen
manchmal müssen Parteien erst in die
Opposition Rücken um wieder offen für
gewisserkenntnisse zu werden so
jedenfalls mein Eindruck aus Sichtung
des Antrags der cdu/csu sie wollen eine
wärmewende sie wollen fossile
Brennstoffe endlich ersetzen sie sehen
im Ausbau der Erneuerbaren eine enormes
und nationales beschäftigungs- und
Wertschöpfungspotenzial
da freue ich mich doch glatt dass wir
endlich auf demselben Level angekommen
sind und miteinander dazu kommunizieren
und das findet auch statt in der Tat die
dramatische Lage unser Gebäude ist keine
neue Erkenntnis aber die erst mit dem 24
Februar 22 eingetreten ist dass sie den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren verschleppt und
unser Land schlecht vorbereitet haben
dass sie von cdu/csu sich um eine
wärmewende bisher wenig geschert haben
und dass sie für billiges russisches Gas
mehr zählte als der Zustand unserer
Gebäude und die Not der Klimakrise all
das ist seit dem 24 februar für alle in
diesem Land einfach nur sichtbarer
geworden das war davor doch schon da die
prekäre Lage in der wir uns befinden ist
das Erbe ihrer Untätigkeit
[Applaus]
sie fordern in ihren Antrag ein Fahrplan
für die wärmewende der Fahrplan liegt
doch seit einem Jahr mit dem
Koalitionsvertrag vor gucken Sie bitte
mal rein wir haben in diesem Jahr mit
dem osterpaket die größte
energiepolitische Gesetzesnovelle seit
Jahrzehnten verabschiedet wir haben das
Wind an Land gesetzt beschlossen ein
Bundesgesetz für kommunale wärmeplanung
ist in der Mache wir bereiten derzeit
den ordnungspolitischen Rahmen vor um
unsere Heizungssysteme langfristig auf
erneuerbare umzustellen die gesetzliche
Regelung dazu kommt in den kommenden
Monaten und greift mit ausreichend
notwendiger Vorlaufzeit Anfang 24 und
damit gibt es Planungs- und
Investitionssicherheit für Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und die ganze Branche
wie sie richtig in ihrem Antrag
ausführen liegt das Durchschnittsalter
von Heizungsanlagen in Deutschland bei
17 Jahren im Osten noch deutlich darüber
wir haben Gewalt jetzt ganz viel zu tun
zur über 75% sind das nach wie vor noch
Gas und Ölheizung das ist wahrlich eine
Herkulesaufgabe vor der wir stehen um
sie erfreulicher ist aber und das wurde
etwas unterbelichtet zur Zeit dass die
Umstellung längst begonnen hat schon in
diesem Jahr gibt es nämlich 230.000 neue
Wärmepumpen hätte niemand gedacht Anfang
März sie werden staun wenn sie mit der
Handwerkerschaft reden wir alles Lust
hat das einzubauen der Markt wirkt der
aktiviert ganz viel Kapazitäten ich bin
da etwas zuversichtlicher und zwar nicht
etwas träumerisch sondern sehr gut
begründet
unsere breite Kommunikation und der
wärmepumpengipfel und die Zuversicht und
der Erkenntnis der Menschen dass es
nicht mehr zurück zur fossilen geht
wirkt nämlich und auch die Sicherheit
dass mit viel Wind und viel Sonne die
Preise deutlich sinken werden wenn von
ihnen von cdu/csu die wärmewende
wirklich am Herzen ein Herzensanliegen
ist dann sorgen Sie gerade auch Liebe
cdu/csu aus meinem Bundesland aus
Sachsen dafür dass auch der nötige
antriebstoff dafür da ist treiben sie
den Ausbau von Windkraft solange die mit
an und Herren mit Verlaub gesagt in
aktuell ist der Zeit wird hier schon
wieder behindert das können wir uns
nicht mehr leisten das darf genau das
gegen den Gründen nicht sein Sie werden
wissen
sie stark für kommunale wärmepläne und
hören Sie endlich auf die Menschen zu
erzählen dass wir eine wärmewende vor
allem mit Wasserstoff und Holz schaffen
das ginge nicht vielen Dank
Bernhard Herrmann hat sich der bedankt
aus den Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
es Mitglied im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie das gilt auch für den
nächsten Redner der ist eigentlich nur
Mitglied sondern auch Vorsitzender Klaus
Ernst aus der Linksfraktion
eine kleine Vorbemerkung zur CDU ich
habe mich über diesen Antrag sehr
gefreut er riecht spricht absolut
richtige Punkte an auch die
technologieoffenheit bei diesen Fragen
die würde ich voll unterstützen ich
frage mich aber auch warum in solche
Dinge auch vor allen Dingen der Punkt
sozial in ihrer Überschrift immer dann
erst richtig einfällt wenn sie in der
Opposition sind das ist so ein ich bin
jetzt ich habe jetzt diese Folge gesetzt
im 17 18 Jahren im Bundestag und da ist
mir das aufgefallen das war ja nicht
immer so dass sie sich gerade dem
sozialen zu machen aber mich freut sich
natürlich dass sie es machen ich stimme
Ihnen vollkommen zu dass wir auch im
Heizbereich Klimaneutralität so schnell
wie möglich erreichen werden müssen da
muss aber genau eben dieser soziale
Aspekt im Vordergrund sehen wir haben
von diesen 17
Jahren gesprochen was das
Durchschnittsalter von Bestandsbauten
und so weiter ist wenn Sie sich
anschauen wie hoch das Volumen ist dass
an Förderung fließen muss damit die
Leute die in diesen Wohnungen sind die
sind unter anderem auch die die wenig
verdienen wie hoch also das
Fördervolumen sein muss dass das
einigermaßen vernünftig über die Bühne
geht dann wird deutlich dass wir da sehr
sehr viel Arbeit haben und dass er sehr
viel Geld in die Hand nehmen wollen
müssen wenn wir das erreichen wollen was
unsere Ziele sind also insofern ist das
ja richtig was Sie wollen aber das muss
uns klar sein um mich freuen darf
insofern dass sie das mit dem sozial
durchaus auch immer
das Problem ist allerdings dass zurzeit
im Land nicht alle unsere Vorschläge zur
wärmewende interessieren sondern sich
eher dafür interessieren ob es überhaupt
eine warme Band haben in ihrer Wohnung
weil sie sich das nicht mehr leisten
können was man gegenwärtig für Preise
haben schon darüber diskutiert die
Hälfte der Haushalte in Deutschland
heißt mit Erdgas ein weiteres Viertel
heißt mit Öl der Preis für Heizöl ist
allein seit Jahresbeginn um fast 60%
gestiegen der für Erdgas hat sich
verdreifacht und das ist das Problem was
ich auch den Grünen mal sagen möchte
relativ klar dass die Preissteigerungen
nicht nur deshalb kommen weil der Pute
nicht mehr liefern will sondern weil wir
Sanktionen machen
wenn man sich das vorher überlegt hätte
man vielleicht anders gemacht und genau
das ist das Problem durch die
gestiegenen Preise haben sie natürlich
jetzt ein Zielkonflikt sie können das
was wir umweltpolitisch machen wollen
sozusagen nicht mehr richtig finanzieren
weil den Leuten die das Geld wird hätten
wir vernünftige Preise hätten wir nicht
ein abschöpfen sozusagen der Kaufkraft
für Energie die sich selbst mit
verursacht haben hätten wir doch eine
andere Lage und das gilt nicht nur für
diesen Bereich sondern das gilt
natürlich auch für den Ausstoß von CO2
der Umstieg oder der ist weg vom Gas das
sie selbst nur verursacht haben auch
mehr Kohle auf andere Energieträger ist
natürlich CO2 freundlichen Killer und
das nehmen sie in Kauf und das finde ich
nicht in Ordnung
sagt Klaus Ernst der vorsitzender ist im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie in
dieser Debatte wo in der so mein Antrag
leonionsfraktion zur wärmewende geht und
das Wasser fast schon von uns während
wir ihm noch mal diesen schönen Schwenk
zeigen von der Kuppel des Bundestages
runter in den Plenarsaal wo die Debatte
im Moment natürlich noch ein wenig
weitergehen wird insgesamt so haben wir
mal grob ausgerechnet vielleicht wenn
ich allzu viele Reden zu Protokoll
gegeben werden deshalb drei in der Nacht
allerdings wird wahrscheinlich diese
Uhrzeit dann doch den ein und anderen
Abgeordneten davon abhalten seine Rede
hier persönlich zu halten sondern da
geht es tatsächlich zu Protokoll gegeben
morgen wird es wieder spannend um 9 Uhr
hier im Bundestag da geht es unter
anderem Umänderungen des
Aufenthaltsgesetzes zum Beispiel am
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht soll gearbeitet
werden bzw das soll etabliert werden das
wie Asylverfahren werden zu Diskussion
stehen und das wird wahrscheinlich
genauso spannend werden wie die dieses
aktuelle Stunde die wir vorhin gesehen
haben zu diesem Kommentar und auf dieses
Thema bereiten Sie wir Sie wie gewohnt
vor nämlich schon um viertel neun mit
einem Interview hier von der Plenarsaal
Ebene im Deutschen Bundestag und wir
freuen uns auf zwei
Bundestagsabgeordnete die beide aus
Berlin sind und die beide
Generalsekretäre ihrer Parteien sind
nämlich Kevin Kühnert und Mario caya
also einschalten nicht erst um viertel
von neun dann würden wir das Gespräch
gerne auch schon früher und gerne so
lange sie mögen bei Phoenix und jetzt
nicht abschalten denn es geht
hochinteressant weiter bei uns aber
nicht aus Berlin sondern aus unserer
sende Zentrale in Bonn und da gebe ich
jetzt hin und bedanke mich für die
bisherige Aufmerksamkeit bei ihnen
schönen Abend noch bei Phoenix
aktuell engagiert meinungsstark Impulse
für die europäische Einrichtung und
Mieten Explosion
werden
was dabei herauskommt die Phönix Runde
heute um 22 Uhr mit diesem Thema
[Musik]
und jederzeit auf phoenix.de
Phoenix der Tag
willkommen zur nachmittagsausgabe von
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg dringt
in der Debatte über neue Waffensysteme
für die Ukraine vor allem darauf dass
die bereits gelieferten rüstungsgü